hopefully we are doing it proper all
right and maybe we're live all right
guys if we're live and you can hear us
please for the love of God say something
I'm giv up on you can you hear please
say something I I need I need the
confirmation okay we back we got okay
and sound Astro thank you asro uh don't
worry I'm going to go into some stuff
before we anything right he asked about
us doing a stream during uh new Rockstar
break room so I was like oh yeah get
that cross promotion Christian respect
and appreciation that's good to hear so
I told the people today at noon alrighty
cool guys well welcome to part two of
our live stream today I don't know what
happened there and I just had to restart
everything and it seemed to get the job
done time Jump plug and plug it back in
but uh thank you guys so much for being
here I'm just tweeting this stream out
let's give some shout outs really quick
to everyone who's in the Stream so far
that we can see right now coy got Jane
Taylor Nadem seek iock house Ginger geek
Quinn World zinc John himself penil
Audrey s glad you love the Marvels AJ
Steve from Brooklyn from Brooklyn
Richard Tito all right cool we got we
got Nam let see here let's see here the
panda no I mean there's people who
already doing the post credit scene
breakdowns and stuff Serena may all
righty guys we'll have spoilers cuz it's
it's Saturday well let's swing in action
CU I'm sure there's going to be plenty
to talk about I did see that we got a
couple of super chats already on the the
last stream but don't worry we will make
sure to uh cover those and but before we
go into any of that uh I'm going to make
sure there's um uh video chapters this
time around I'm going to make the
concerted effort to do video chapters we
will call this chapter some heads UPS
all right that's chapter one let me
write that down some heads UPS so if
you're watching this on the playback
feel free to skip it uh before koi takes
over the stream because he's going to
have a lot to say we both will uh first
things first please leave a like on this
that helps with the playback when I say
playback that means after the stream is
done does this continue to be seen and
recommended and a lot of times live
streams have a difficult time doing that
and that's why we welcome super chats
and streamlabs because the playbacks on
these are are rather rough and how we
normally interact uh with with it so
some people think that we just ignore
the chat but we don't ignore the chat we
don't what we normally do is we kind of
let the super chats and such uh sort of
guide conversation but then we're always
seeing what the chat is saying here and
and Garfield apparently in venom 3
according to the chat that's exciting to
hear according to the chat I'm the new
Tyron Magnus would you hold them I said
I I was reading it I said I needed to
get through this chapter before you take
over what is the first thing on my
document before koi takes over it says
it right there it's right there all
right gosh Greg's turn go what was I
saying about the what was I saying this
is why there's chapters that exist
anyway um Super Chat how difficult so
yeah whatever and then uh so last lastly
what I'm going to say right now too is
uh I know some people are going to be
asking where's John H I did want Jon for
this one in fact uh I was the plan was
to actually have it be John and Koy this
time around uh so we'll call this
chapter chapter two will be called
where's John I like that so that if John
is watching some playback hopefully he
enjoys what I got to say here so
basically um on Thursday the day of Loki
actually I don't want to go into John's
personal life about any specific details
he did experience um a loss I'll put it
like that and uh he was cool enough I
didn't realize this till right before
the Loki finale actually or maybe like
right after that he had this loss but he
still stuck around the entire night gave
his a game and then he even helped out a
lot because like the prepper team who
helps us with videos they they were out
they're out of town for several days and
so he was helping me get ahead while I
was editing the Loki video so he power
through that and then there was this
commitment for the wish press stuff junk
it that he couldn't get out of so he had
to commit to that and this is on top of
already having a very long Thursday
while dealing with this law so I was
like you know what he he has a
commitment he has to do later on today
so I was like just you can take this
Saturday morning and afternoon to
yourself so uh yeah I just wanted to
give John a little bit of a break uh
right now after being a trooper while
dealing with some real things right now
and I really did want him in this stream
and I'm only saying this uh just if
John's watching this on playback I'm
only saying this uh to make me look good
yeah yeah this isn't actually about you
this isn't about you this is about me
looking good by complimenting you I hope
Greg the good person subtext where's
John yeah exactly gets I get it my wish
is that you are in an Alleyway right now
uh Downing a bottle of malt liquor with
a disheveled beard homeless yeah walking
into a bar seeing this clap clip out
featured on Fox News and you're like oh
he used to be my boss and my best friend
what happened and they don't know who
you are it happened quick that's how you
in the last like hour last hour that's
impressive she spirals man he did
already have the beard luckily and like
frankly you can get a bottle anywhere so
okay it's it's possible but anyway guys
um yeah that's I just can't leave it on
a nice sentiment all righty guys well
here we go guys let's get into things
wish John some positive vibes Greg is a
good person now that's funny thank you
Ray Stevenson yes guys thank you so much
for being here um now we want to talk
obviously there's going to be spoilers
here Loki season 2 finale the Marvels uh
Koy was not with John and I when we
talked about the Marvel thank you
everyone's been sending super chats
really appreciate that uh we we did not
before we go into any of the specific
topics in the chat right now y uh really
quick Koy we'll call this chapter Ko's
quick thoughts and the Marvels quick
thoughts what did you think about the
Marvels remember remember MH in the end
y still positive
majority I think yeah I I don't know I I
mean it it's it's still a fun time I'm
saying play co don't be honest right no
no can't be honest uh no I mean I I I've
said from the beginning even with my not
loving it as much as others have that
you should see it if you want to like I
don't think that my experience of it
should affect yours in any way
whatsoever uh I've never really
understood the idea of uh a Critic a
pundit or a viewer someone on the
internet a stranger you don't know
having any impact over your experience
whatsoever but I do like sharing
opinions which is why you know we do
this on the internet but uh if you want
to see it you should see it and I hope
you did and I hope you enjoyed it my
experience wasn't as positive as I would
have liked um I really really think um
this movie felt like it was ruined in
post I feel like the scripts uh and the
edit felt like they were
both made by committee not made by Art
uh it did feel like it was trying to
serve many purposes none of which felt
like the emotional weight that the
characters deserved or the actors
deserved that they actors were
delivering uh I did feel like the Nea
dasta directing which is this really
beautiful sweeping uh operatic camera
style was really undermined by the way
it was edited I do feel like we had some
beautiful arcs that had potential in the
writing before it was whatever happened
uh there were amazing moments where we
could have had this what happened
between Monica and Carol in their time
away and how did they each feel about it
and mourn this great reveal about Carol
that didn't really feel like it landed
and and the ramifications of that with
Monica the for
between one scene um the Aman valani
being such a Powerhouse in this film I
really really really think Aman valani
is a movie star now she's in a movie as
well as a TV show it was beautiful to
see her charm uh on a big scale but I do
feel like they didn't utilize the power
that is a Manan valani as well as they
could have because I didn't feel the
relationship between her and Carol got
its time to breathe much less evolve
into like her losing this golden vage of
hero and then getting it back she she
did have moments where she doubted the
power of of this Wonder of her hero but
then it didn't really get any time to to
flesh itself out as they repaired that
relationship and it felt like they they
implied at the end that you know Monica
would have been like a a surrogate
little sister uh had she stayed and it
felt like Miss Marvel was going to
become that for Captain Marvel in the
end kind of like I didn't uh succeed in
in this relationship I'd like to try to
work at this one I've learned my lesson
didn't feel that at all uh and and I do
feel like they rushed a lot of Beats
like the entire Arc with Monica you know
saying like you can't do this you're
better than this you should try to grow
create I love the message of creation
versus destruction go see uh Godzilla
minus one I love the idea of power and
and what it is to use your power
benevolently and then they were just
like you can restart the sun can I maybe
I don't know flies and does it okay
peace 30 seconds it just felt um felt
rushed it felt uh hamfisted rushed and
it felt like nasta deserved better and
certainly Carol Danvers who found her
way through this bre Aron performance I
really enjoyed Breeze take here as Carol
dver much more but I didn't get to see a
lot of it because they kept cutting
other stuff like it just it felt erratic
um so Aman valani I think did absolutely
everything she could I think that Tia
Paris did everything she could and I
think Brie Larson improved Carol Danvers
so much for me but it's still the movie
itself felt like a series of different
dishes someone took like a lot of
recipes and they shuffled them and then
they set the oven to maybe and we got
some sort of meal well well I will say
that uh yeah I like everything that
you're saying I'm also reading the
entire chat and it is interesting
because I'm seeing the divisiveness
already occurring within the chat so I'm
gonna ask you guys right now put down in
the chat I've been reading everyone's
comments while while SC was talking put
down in the chat what your rating was of
of of the Marvels and then of course uh
what is your rating of the Marvels and
then also um yeah loky season 2 if you
guys didn't catch our reaction for it uh
we absolutely loved it y we'll talk
about that next time I'm sure I'm sure
we're GNA start with the Marvels uh and
someone saying how long did I want the
movie to take as long as it needed to a
story should go on as long as it should
not seven out of 10 7 out of 10
6.56 six7 oh look that's a that's a
woman there and 4.5 6.5 six 6.5 a lot
mainly in the sixes to sevens fours but
it looks like it's mainly between the
five to six range right here solid six
out of 10 five out of 10 okay so yeah
most of it is seems like it's like
looking at this I I don't feel like I'm
incorrect on assessing this it seems to
primarily be hovering in the six range I
see more sixes or I see fours and seven
so I would say the average there there's
the occasional 10 n obviously we see
those but on average yeah um I'll admit
on our review let's call Greg expanding
on his Marvel's review chapter four yeah
CU I know we really want to talk about a
Loki season 2 as well it's going to be
an interesting stream because we're
going be hopping around here um one
thing that I wish as I was actually
putting the video together uh for for
our Marvel's talk uh John was actually
over my shoulder and I was like thank
God you're here John because this is the
most incomprehensible I have ever
sounded like the entire time I was
listening to myself talk I just kept
thinking of that Michael Scott meme when
Toby shows up and he's just going no no
no and I realized the it was a unique
viewing experience for me because I I
have gotten so used to filming movie
reactions here
not that when I am having a criticism
where I'm upset with something normally
I can just vocalize it in the moment and
it was also sort of piling up that by
the time I got out of the screening and
um people were most most people were
surrounded by really like the movie that
I didn't want to argue with anyone I
don't I never want to be that guy who's
like oh you liked it let me tell you why
I don't like I I hate those people I
don't I don't hate those people I hate
when people do that a bunch of people
said they weren't going to watch our
live cuz we didn't like it and I said
good like I exactly that yeah yeah so I
get it and and and and I could
understand if people didn't watch it
because I was so a I was so I was just
leading with my emotions and I wasn't
really coming intellectually at all and
I'll gladly admit that H because yeah I
mean the what I've I've expressed what I
didn't really like about it I do think
the writing was poorly done but one
thing I I didn't really siphon that out
because I was like these movies are when
we say heavily produced or heavily
edited you could that is usually when
you are associating that you could feel
Studio Mandate of trim so I can't really
comment so much on the writing and go
this is the writer's fault and it's this
is not some like you know uh I'm here to
defend the writers after everything
they've been through I'm just it's just
like from ex from knowing how things go
down you're like this this feels more
like whatever the if there is a good
script or whatever the the original
script was this probably wasn't the case
you could feel the chop chop chop chop
and that's why I focus more on how the
movie was edited how it skipped around
and the pacing and whatnot were the
things that upset me and when I say Aman
volani was great I've always loved Iman
volani and I've always said that she's
one of the best cast actors and I think
the three actresses their chemistry is
great in the film it it just a lot of it
like the singing scene I thought was
really everything about
it overall if I were to condense them
like there is a version of this movie
that would have worked I love what it
was planting it just didn't like
flourish the flower didn't grow like
everything everywhere all at once is a
great example of a movie that is
bombastic a crazy cacophony of events
moves at a at a whiplash pace is so
strange and so
surreal and they do like some of the
most wacky but then they could also
hit you with such dramatic heft and I'm
not saying this movie even needs to
touch the caliber of film making I'm
saying that
it's possible when you have wacky stuff
like flurin swallowing people you know
you need emotional weight or musical
numbers it's the flow it's the way the
film is executed overall that where that
stuff felt empty to me and I will and I
I will say like I there were parts that
I definitely laughed at during the movie
like where it felt intentional like this
good funny this is actually funny you
know um but you know I and and the other
thing I'll clarify I see this coming up
in the chat quite a bit right now is the
post credit scene of what upset me about
it now this is more of like a
technicality thing that I know a lot of
people will not agree with me on no one
has agreed with me yet yeah that's fine
I've talked to so many people yeah dude
I I what I what really really bothers me
about the post credit scene this is
going to sound like a nitpick hear me
out of why it bothers me and if you
don't agree I'm totally okay some people
think I'm mad if you don't agree with me
I I last live stream heavily encouraged
let it's okay to disagree I I encourage
conversation I really really encourage
it I I I want everyone to just be honest
with each other bottom line and what
bothers me about the post credit scene
and you've probably heard some people
mention it is the fact that they did CGI
Beast why this bothers me so much is MCU
has more money and time than any of the
X-Men movies and we just we've seen
several X-Men movies with Nicholas Holt
a couple with appearances from Kelsey
Grammar as Beast where they used
practical effects which helps it feel
more real and the CGI around it was I
the second he showed up I think I I
think you heard me say out loud like
they CGI Beast yeah we both kind of like
uh with there was a moment of excitement
it was half a second cuz as soon as you
realize The Uncanny Valley it drops cuz
my very first Instinct was oh it's more
comic accurate but then as soon as he
moved at all like it was one second of
happiness cuz he did look more comic
accurate but then as soon as he moved it
felt like there was again like the
emotional weight there was no physical
weight to beast and I was like oh this
is way too important of a character and
way too important of an introduction and
and I joked on on uh on new rock stars
the other day that it it was the
animated like X-Men 97 beast that's
that's what we brought in like we
literally have representation I
understand that the CGI is to try to
match an aesthetic but at the end of the
day however would say at the end of the
day it doesn't look believable it
doesn't look real and it doesn't excite
me for the return of Beast because it
was liken it to how when people felt
when they first saw Yoda in in The
Phantom Menace there's a reason great
example there's a reason why when the
trilogy I mean granted the Disney
Trilogy is not exactly the greatest
thing to defend here one thing that a
lot of people were happy about though
was they brought Yoda back as a
practical
because that's what helps it feel
tangible and real and I think MCU if
they want like the tangibility of the
emotional weight you need to be able to
do that why why wouldn't you want an
emotional reaction to a post credit
scene like why do you want not quality
like why why are you defending a lack of
something in the chat it's really y'all
are
weird I just don't understand why you'd
be upset with something working like why
would not you strive for the best like
why not want the weight of we've had the
X we've already succeeded at it why
accept a diminishing return that's just
a weird thing to defend I didn't even
see the person's name but they're dumb
hey these are actual subscribers koi
well they're being to me they're going
insult me I'm I literally gave my
opinion and was very kind and patient
with you all and I see a few people
defending me but like I'm not insulting
your like you and you're you're you're
not insulting my opinion you're
insulting me so you oh just that
one person not everyone no there was a
few moving on Sorry God damn Coy I'm
trying to keep things civil sitting here
on a Saturday I don't need to be here
with these and I'm I'm a wanting
attention I changes my opinion to fit in
I don't know how you think having a
Nuance take on a movie is changing my
opinion to fit others when I'm one of
the people in the exception to have
really quick Nadem Che practical effects
werewolf by night did it yeah and it
looks great in color and black beast
Kelsey Grammar shows up in Days of
Future Past for approximately the same
amount of screen time that he's hitting
the Marvel's post credit scene practical
effects and and to me
I I like really it bothers me that they
won't embrace it uh so yeah that's a
real thing but anyway uh the other thing
that I wanted to do I'll call this
chapter you guys forget
stuff I got this message and we will get
to all the super chats and everything
right now we're reading obviously
obviously we're reading this is four
gonna be Greg expands or you guys forget
so is this five no this is uh no this is
four or oh I'm just wondering did you
want to do four I got you than you
brother there we go ad Force you don't
forget it chapter four was Greg expands
yes there we go I got you accountability
I'm paying attention all right let's go
here okay so one thing that I will like
I'm totally okay with people disagreeing
with us on anything right I could handle
whatever hate you guys are throwing our
way the thing that I feel I do not want
us to be lumped in with because we
weren't fans of the movie the
Marvels is the the crowd that is
obviously feeds into whenever there's a
woman on screen they go they scream woke
and they scream virtue signaling and
they scream Disney pandering and
whatever because I refused to be lumped
into that category I know right away
people will lump us into it just
yesterday uh one of our I won't say who
one of our patrons sent a very lengthy
uh message to us about how they felt
like after them loving the Marvels they
feel like John and I are people who are
suddenly like part of that crowd who
can't understand superhero females and
and yada yada yada and I expected I
expected people just to immediately
think have that black and white thinking
we're dealing with the internet
obviously I I get it and that's one of
the things and also the other thing is
writing an MCU hate train because I'm
like so many things are being forgotten
about out M um I loved black panther
with Connor forever and a lot of people
did it a lot of people talk about it I
really loves sh in the Black Panther
role I love Sher in that film we are two
people here on camera who often get a
lot of crap for liking a television
series called
She-Hulk we really like it we loved Miss
Marvel yeah uh Wonder Woman is my top 20
I think comic films period ball every
time I watch it Birds of Prey is another
movie get a lot of crap for in
conversation for really really liking a
lot and I'll probably get it right now
for it like it more Mo sniders lady
director all female cast really loved it
and I like the fact that we I'm going to
keep the clarification on this really
short I just don't want us to be lumped
into that specific category I just love
that we have to list women I know that's
to prove that women are good that's a
because I and I even said in our talk
like I had no issues with the actresses
in this movie yeah I I don't also I just
quickly saw someone say qu act sexist I
don't know how with the amount of
Defense of this movie building up that I
did I could
possibly ah I just I only have so many
fucku yeah that's that's basically it um
so that's what I wanted to get into and
clarify
uhy I just I'm doing it Cal you are
passionate human being and I love it so
you know what no you lead as much as you
want should we play relaxing um we have
enough like I like that we have
subscribers on this channel we have
enough that I can lose some you you
you
could uh but yeah I think it's an
interesting problem when you can't have
criticism and not be able to even
establish the Nuance take on it before
you're lumped into something because
that's the difference and that's what I
think there's a lack of media literacy
around is there's a lot of people that
don't have media literacy that are just
mad because there is woman or someone
with opinion or this and that and then
we get put into that because we're
explaining the nuanced reasons involving
editing and writing and wanting better
for these characters that are women and
these actresses that are women and I
don't understand the lack of
comprehension between the difference
between a yelling woke making dumb faces
in your thumbnail o over the faces of
actresses or like using uh silly memes
antagonistically versus us going wow
this was disappointing because we had
such expectations
and we as viewers as well as the people
that made this movie deserve better like
there is a completely different
fundamental judgment and there's a
completely different fundamental
assessment from our point and I don't
think that if you can't understand the
difference in that you deserve to have
our commentary or deserve to enjoy this
art if you can't comprehend any it's not
even Nuance it's black and white
thinking if you can't comprehend good
bad right wrong uh uh judgments then you
don't deserve art yeah and the only
thing that we can do you got to
understand a lot of thing too is that
some people think a lot I've got a this
message I get the thing is it's weird
when like okay this is showed up been my
DMs it's one thing if it's just comments
on YouTube whatever and and one of the
comments that when I before I made the
video public for the Marvel's video the
comment that I put up was specifically I
think it was specifically This was
um have you decided whether you like
this movie or not before you watched it
because that is is specifically going
after people who make up their mind
about it meaning I don't want you to
just take my word for it and I'm not
trying to tell you not to watch this
movie you should form your own opinion
because that's what we encourage
throughout both of our views yeah yeah
that's what we always want that's what
we always want and and I and I I I will
champion this side of the conversation a
lot of people will say just ignore hate
ignore whatever uh this is something
that I actively would like to push back
against though personally
same that's why like we're doing this
feel because it's it's really
frustrating it makes the job really hard
because if you like everything which
people claim I do up until this point
where I became fill in your alt-right
here then you don't have the
ability to say uh something is if
everything's a five nothing's a five if
everything's a 10 nothing's a 10 I'm
just a mean drunk that's true but if you
uh if you are start being critical then
all of a sudden there's this animosity
because they're so used to you liking
things so it's it's really if if you
don't want opinions of people don't
listen to them like I don't understand
the goal here and I will one thing I
also want to say too is uh it's awesome
seeing how many people are in this chat
like this is on slow mode and the chat
is just blowing up and I love it I love
seeing it I love seeing it guys and I'm
glad to everyone who had a good time
with it like I said I could see a
version where people had a lot of fun
with with the Marvels um and yeah I'm
sure we will go into a little bit more
positive stuff I thought Loki would be
the predominant conversation yeah
because we got to go into that
but been loving the comments uh I I want
to catch up on some of the super chats
but don't worry I'm going to keep this
chat going and we will be keeping
interactive we know CO's gonna not
ignore what's going on in this chat as
much Asal Health demands we know
ity you just you just deal with it just
handle it I was in such a good mood
before sitting down in front of the
internet this was such a such a decision
on such a terrible idea I woke up so
happy I had such a good 36 hours and
then I was like what did you expect that
we're talking about the Marvel said we
had a specific if we hadn't had this
plan for 2 weeks there's no reality
where the 3 hours we're about to endure
is going to be worth losing my co my God
realize something Coy if we loved the
Marvels we would be getting the exact
opposite thing in the chat true the
other people would be in here we don't
need to be upset like we would be
getting the exact opposite thing in the
chat right now that's I can only be so
disappointed in humanity Greg if there's
only so low I can think of people if we
loved it people would say you just
you're woke your Disney Shields and blah
blah blah and if you like if you don't
like it you're you know you're all these
other things that we don't know how to
have fun or some right Greg
being The Optimist is really this is a
Twist guys what this is I have dealt
with so much crap in the past few days I
know that's that's what I'm saying it's
this is nothing to me right now it's
very impressive that I absolutely
nothing that's the twist I didn't expect
from our Saturday yeah man uh it's fine
like I also realize the main person
that's been bothering me is someone
named bullets Nation I realize I
shouldn't care about someone is
literally named after a to kill we're a
right now uh wow we got a good amount of
super chats and oh my God we can talk
about Loki yes say but guys leave down
your I'm encouraging leave down the
positive stuff for the Marvels too you
know like admittedly my mind would not
go to the positive stuff and I'd like to
go to the positive stuff so leave leave
down some of those positive things
because ENC encourage the conversation
in that way um doesn't need like we'll
just see how the conversation goes
basically
Koy how you feeling buddy this is fun
yeah I love seeing Vex Koy it's uh it's
not a common thing the only time I'm
quiet is when I'm like past mad it's
like when I'm mad I just yell but when
I'm like livid I'm like I love people
because I think we fundamentally like
sharing art is so important to like the
emotional expression of humanity like I
think art is about like you you you have
a trauma in your life because that's
existing and then you make something out
of it so other people can feel seen and
I think art is so beautiful and
wonderful so the reason these Marvel
movies are so special is because it's
able to get so many people to understand
someone's pain someone's art someone's
experience so the fact that we've taken
this beautiful thing that is cinema this
beautiful thing that is these moving
pictures of Sight and Sound that
thousands of people work on and we can't
look at them and expect them to be
better and we can't give any sort of
like nuanced appreciation positive or
negative about them because the internet
has become such a consistent cess poool
that it causes people that want to
actually study them for better or worse
to hate the very people they're trying
to conversations with like it's it's
just disgusting that we made the
internet to hate instead of to love like
this is an incredible connecting tool
and it's just such a waste a lot of the
times big problems happen in
interactions due to a lack of
communication or
miscommunication and often times in
relationships that's what you'll find is
like oh a lot of this comes down to oh
it's just kind of a miscommunication at
the end of the day and what saddens me
about the about like internet
interaction is a lot of people who
interact on the internet actually
logically know this and yet still
participate this way in such a black and
white way of discussing things and a lot
of vitriol and bile and and a lot of
people know this prior being around on
this planet before the internet came
into existence and what worries me about
the future is there are children who are
growing up in it who who are going to
learn this is the way to communicate
with people that's what concern we're
already seeing it more look like like
people the way people don't know how to
be in public oh those people can go
themselves right dle yeah no it's bad
but that's going to be that's the micro
it's going to be the macro let's top
talk into this all right our first Super
Chat is about Superman what do you know
thank we'll get eventually we'll get toi
but from C Cinema thanks for kicking off
the super chats today buddy he says uh
the end reminds me of an all of all
Superman when Clark flies into the sun
to oh he's talking about Loki season 2
okay are here we are the end reminds me
of all when Superman when Clark flies
into the sun to fix the damage done to
it he'll be back he just has work to do
first uh this is an interesting
conversation because at the end of Loki
season 2 now Coy do you want to clarify
that because you were under the Imp and
I believe the impression you were under
because I was like Coy must be right uh
was that you you believe that koi was
not that koi that the koi was at the
beginning of time oh I still do and I I
know because everyone is saying like
literally every other video is saying
that he took over he who remains and is
in the end of he he has replaced him see
I don't see that I I still personally
and I think it's meant to be
interpretive like it didn't he didn't
like kick him out and sit in his chair I
I interpreted it as there has to be
balance there has to be creation and
there has to be destruction you don't
see him ending any timelines you don't
see him ending any any new branches like
he's only growing them he's only so I I
personally and you know uh I the video
that I posted um about my theory Justin
and Aaron liked so I feel like that
to it but they could just have liked
what I had to say because art should be
interpretive uh but uh to me he's
creating and he's witnessing and he's
growing timelines whereas at the end of
time I don't think that'd be where you'd
be nurturing and growing uh also there
doesn't seem to be any um benevolence or
malevolence it seems very like reserved
like he just has to monitor it seems
very like uh not controlling just just
tending you know what I mean so that to
me doesn't register as the Kang roll uh
I I don't see that being the way it
would go uh but I also think that
depending on how the story of K goes
forward with everything that might
change like I think the reason the
ending is so uh beautifully interpretive
is because now we've got a chance to not
bring Kang back or bring one of the
kangs back depending on how things go in
real life okay so um what do we call
this chapter then lowkey season 2
discussion just broad discussion oh no
Coy that's boring Loki season 2 what
does it
mean beginning of T I'll figure it out
okay not end of time because like I I
don't think guys what should I call this
chapter of what KO just said because I I
honestly I don't think it works to have
him just replace Kang because that
doesn't allow for Kang to have a purpose
and we didn't see Kang not but it seemed
like he went to the chair that he who
remains sat upon it is now thrashed and
then he rebuilt it in the golden chair
the throne oh see I never interpreted
that I interpreted that space as just
like a metaphysical space about time not
the not the Citadel itself like I I
personally interpreted and Justin and
Aaron liked your post yeah but they
could just like that what I had to say
like that's the be of comics like I'm
not claiming that them liking my post
there are some people who agree with you
man uh so I but like that's just how I
interpreted it because I don't think we
would have had that is uh abstract of a
a visual if it was going to be such a
linear idea like the linear idea is new
guy that monitors time as Loki and it
wasn't a linear presentation it was a
very beautifully abstract Norse
representation of like the Tree of Life
which would have nothing to do with Kang
like I don't think they would have gone
through all of that beauty and wonder if
it was just like you're out of a job
Kang like that's he literally built uh
like he was creation itself so I don't
think he would have built if he
just sat in a chair that was already
there that doesn't make any sense
regardless beautiful ending oh my God
and um yeah I uh the Deadshot is right
here thank you Deadshot for your Super
Chat my friend and and I'm seeing people
in the chat that really a lot there's a
lot of people obviously some people have
a different interpretation but there's
actually quite a few who agree with you
yeah I think and that's the beauty of
like when you make art it's like I
didn't used to understand Modern Art
like when I looked at mod art I was like
okay a seven-year-old could do that but
as I've I've gotten old and cranky
apparently uh it's really interesting to
look at art that makes you feel anything
if it's just abstract color because the
old Citadel was still falling apart
right right so so but when you look at
abstract art it's interesting what does
call you and what doesn't and that's why
I really like this finale because it
wasn't linear Marvel it was really an
abstract art piece and the rest of the
season whether they were doing those
voyerism Shakespearean shots where it
was almost like the characters were
talking to you whether or not they were
using the blend of comic medium and TV
medium to have those wide sweeping shots
where his his clothing came out to me
this felt like uh the best use of
Television for a comic because it BL Ed
mediums like abstract Arc like like
Shakespearean plays like but did it all
in a way that could only be done in long
form television like this was a six hour
story well for that's a great question
maybe you should get Justin and Aaron on
and then maybe maybe we're already
talking about it now that the strike's
over oh maybe three dead shots
common thank you for the Super Chat my
friend Loki ending was so good in the
beginning Loki uh wanted was a throne
and Rule now he has a throne but not cuz
he wants to but he needs to save the one
he loves burdened by glorious purpose
absolutely that's what I think the arc
is so great about it you know one one
thing I wanted to I mean we talked about
that quite extensively in our in our uh
review following the uh reaction for it
is that uh what I what I wanted to also
expand upon actually I want to take the
STP to say this based off what you just
said that shot I'm just saying it like
this so that way I can justify why I'm
saying it to tied into your Super Chat
is that is that
um one of my things that I was um
sometimes riffing on throughout the
reaction uh for season 2 was I'm kind of
missing some of Loki's personality a
little bit of that mischievous
personality and then I was like but may
kind of waiting to see how this sort of
ends and what I thought I was actually
at the gym thinking about this and it's
throw again that I worked out that's a
show I ran into
Justin because we both work out was that
what was so cool about the start of
season 2 is that he's such a TVA man M
and here he becomes this uh benevolent
Watcher over time because he had to
become a ruler that was not like he who
remains I was not a dictator but one
that serves for the people one that
makes a sacrifice for the people and he
really gets to understand human
connection throughout the season so much
so that he practically be is human for
like the first half of season two yeah
you know what I mean like he's kind of
just a TVA member and once you the end
you realize that he was like placating
time like there there's kind of this a
moment of like he's lived this so many
times he is going through the motions I
think it's a really beautiful Arc and
it's cool that you have one AR you have
two Loki arcs you got you have the Loki
Arc within the MCU movies then you have
this completely separate Loki who has
what the most could have been and that
is so it's one of the greatest
Testaments to what the MCU is capable of
doing truly you know I I thought it was
absolutely thrilling it's up there with
uh the no way home presentation of the
three different personalities of
Spider-Man as like two of them being the
Uncle Ben the third where you're like
this is what a Multiverse can be yeah
and and I honestly think the speech
about um burden with glorious purpose
and the the purpose of burden and the
burden of purpose was so genius because
not only does it play with that iconic
dialogue but it also really linearly
gives you an abstract concept and it
also gives you an abstract concept
really linear like it the the idea of it
itself is Boris like you can ponder the
purpose of burden and the burden of
purpose for for Millennia like it's such
a cool idea that he earned the The
Throne by having to understand that it
was weight not power yeah and that that
is so like even the way the horn shaped
they feel so heavy and the the clothing
feels so uncomfortable it's just it's so
beautiful that's so true COI so true
we'll loosen up throughout the stream
promise all righty so Marco Santos thank
you for the Super Chat I know it looks
like uh Loki became God of stories but
it also look like he became Loki Prime
Loki KY probably knows what I'm talking
about yeah I think there is going to be
a p a prime timeline Prime Loki so
there's like a prime timeline uh
character Prime Time Loki Prime Time
Loki but I think they're going to
introduce um primes in Deadpool because
I think that's going to be the whole Fox
you know kills the fox Universe I think
we're going to try to like make things
linear leading up to Secret Wars so I
think the prime concept is going to be
it's kind of like the inverse of a Canon
event so you know in the in the cross
the spiderverse the Canon event is
something they all share sure in the
idea of prime there is one main
character of characters the rest all
extrapolate out from him so it's kind
like that inverse so I think we're going
to meet um probably as soon as Deadpool
like there's going to be a prime
Wolverine and I'm wondering if that was
actually Logan and because they're
goingon to acknowledge Logan dying so
I'm wondering if Deadpool's gonna be
looking for prime prime Wolverine and
finds out he's dead or if they're going
to make I I hope they don't get kind of
undermine Logan but if they're going to
make another Wolverine Prime that he's
got to find and Hugh Jackman is going to
be that so I think we're going to be
going through a lot of Wolverine's
plural in Deadpool 3 and they're going
to explain the prime concept there okay
sweet oh my God we got to like include
something on this chapter chapter 7even
Prime Time Prime
Loki Deadpool 3 Connection keywords guys
they're coming in SEO yeah Lorenzo baxer
yeah we will talk about that
conversation I just saw your chat uh on
your comment coming no there's there's
so much to deconstruct here I can't wait
to rewatch one and two together uh
because I didn't rewatch season one like
you did right before season two um and
my girlfriend's never seen any Loki so I
want to sit and watch it as like the
movie it's meant to be in the dark
because I'm watching it on camera with
lights is not nearly the same like
immersiveness as like tucking in I'm
sorry I it was fun I'm just
acknowledging it's going to be different
round two danam b900 thank you for being
back here you're always in our streams
really appreciate it uh Camala really
sent it okay we're back to Miss Marvel C
uh the Marvels Camala really sentenced
Al alad to death with the jump and the
only reaction to it was Carol saying not
to be like her could have had a real
convo with Camala learning about hard
decisions but nope that's what I sort of
mean by that like I thought that moment
was going to be kind of the turning
point for me in the Marvel's film where
okay we're going to get some time to
really do something that will have a
little bit more substance to it instead
of let's get back to fun
yeah uh was that the moment he's talking
about is is when like uh Captain Marvel
gets really Stern with with Kamala she
you see that's reaction she has like
almost oh my God wait who are you what
is this decision you're making and I
thought there was such a interesting
conversation to be had with like kind of
over idolizing Your Heroes mentorship
over idolizing The Last Jedi
conversation and becoming more uh human
I don't I don't know what what I'm not
saying like here's what they should have
done I'm saying they clearly opened the
door for something that with filmmaker
and also not forget top credited writer
Nia deosta uh if you look at some of her
previous Works something that gets as
deep as like her remake of Candyman for
example I'm sure had some of the on
her mind yeah because that scene felt
like they were gonna go like that
direction and then the next scene was
like I'm sorry I did that and I was like
why did you
just but yeah that was that was
something there but again like Kamala
Khan uh um Aman volani I incredible
absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible like that was what I met I
met her in person have you met her
before when I met her I got a her that
and I was like this like I met it
similar like I don't know it's like when
I met Dane Cook and I was like I've seen
everyone in your SP just to be able to
like say that even though they're not
going to remember and even though um
Aman bani had recognized us and I was
like oh that's cool yeah it was very I
got to like tell her like an actual
truth which is I have said so many times
that you are one of the best like
arguably the best like most apt casting
of of MCU ever so I was like to be able
to tell her that was was great she is
truly one of us it's amazing but don't
forget we're sexist because we didn't oh
right right right all right mayani is a
woman and I like her May Ravari I think
I nailed that thank you so much my
friend uh hi Greg and Koy love the Loki
season 2 finale my theory the king war
is destroying the Multiverse we should
talk more to the camera don't forget so
there's people in there the king War
destroying the Multiverse so to save
what's left Loki combines remaining
branches in the battle World leading
into Secret Wars I thought about this
too at the when I was freaking out was
because because they keep talking about
or Boris yeah and how crazy of an AA
Boris would it be if and I think there's
something like this that kind of happens
in the comics sort of is how Loki Loki
was the first villain in Avengers yeah
so what if for Secret Wars to making her
ultimate Ora Boris effect he's the big
he's the one who has to assemble
Avengers in order to defeat the big
threat how crazy would that be like oh
our first villain is now becoming the
assembler that is literally the only way
I want Tom hson back I don't want him to
pop up in a lot of stuff I don't want it
to be like oh it's a variant it's not
the prime I I don't want them to waste
the impact of the finale by having and
and he went on The Tonight Show last
night and basically said like it's not
just the conclusion of two seasons of
Television it's the conclusion of 14
years of my life and it was this really
powerful moment for him and I and I
don't know if I want to waste that like
I I really I know how important these
stories are to everyone and I know how
important these stories are to me but
the human that is Tom Heston I want him
to rest I want him to be able to do
other stuff all right someone just
brought it up in the chat um
uh I want to make sure all right remind
me on the next Miss Marvel question
because I want to make sure we're
staying on track because I got an
appointment at 3:30 I gotta go to um
mascar RZ brought up a Haley Steinfeld
in there so remind me on the next Miss
Marvel question we get to talk about the
uh Avers Young Avengers scene yeah yeah
here it is perfect thank you
Christian that's what I'm talking about
literally the next one all right uh
Christian pronounceable uh thank you so
much I'm so happy I actually called Kate
Bishop showing up
to me uh I you know what I like that
scene more than the the mid credit scene
Oh by a lot it felt very accurate to
both tonality of what I mean a from the
movie B what from the Miss Marvel show
for her to like do spoof of Nick Fury
excellent so funny and then even tonally
with what we saw with Kate Bishop in the
Hawkeye series uh I thought that was
excellent I the one thing I was craving
from that
moment it's is not something that makes
it that makes it bad to me the one thing
I was craving was just a shot of both of
them in frame I wonder if they were I
don't know that's the question because
seeing those two that's another
character we absolutely loved oh my God
incred we don't even like the show that
much but she everything she was
everything about oh my God she was
phenomenal and especially if you read
the comic that's mainly inspired by
you're like w wow perfect casting I
think that's why I get so angry is cuz I
feel like I'm doing that like I have a
black friend thing to women yeah I feel
like I have to be like awkward feeling I
love women let me list some yeah I
really love that scene a lot and I I did
I did love that I did not give that
scene Credit in the non-spoiler review
that scene is so good the writing the
delivery even the lighting it was so and
of course Miss Marvel be the one to
spoof Nick Fury like I love that we have
an in Universe character that feels
tonally appropriate to make fun of stuff
and Kate Bishop's response was so
charming and accurate I I think it's
it's so on point I love that she called
out that she's 23 not really a young
Avenger but I didn't I and some people
are saying that they feel that it should
have been Kate Bishop recuring now I
think I think Miss Mar it's definitely
Miss Marvel the way they've set her up
here that she's a I think she's gonna be
a leader as as she matures I got I got a
black friend so said Winston that's your
black friend yeah yeah yeah you guys see
me on a show with him weekly my only one
black friend that was great thank you I
think Loki would show up again no one no
one everyone shows up again I think the
valkyrie Cameo would have been way more
impactful if it wasn't in the trailer um
Trey Porter greetings and salutation
boys thank you for the Super Chat my
friend Deadshot back at it thank you uh
Loki full
circle some people agree better than the
post I think like the setup for the
future is crazier in the post credit
scene which seems to be pulling from the
Days of Future Past Universe yeah it was
a really weird choice to go there of all
of them but maybe that's how they can
have him in certain things and not the
other X-Men to see mavo in them back
Deadshot here we are loky full circle
foreshadow moment is on part A Tony
foreshadowing and sacrificing The Arc
director was able to help him hold
something powerful yeah it's like what's
nuts is that with Iron Man they've had
to kind of improvise it along the way in
terms of like the next like I'm there's
no they did not even have Thanos in mind
until after they shot that random post
credit scene in Avengers yeah so they
did not have this in mind the script
wasn't that Iron Man one yeah it was
that this would be the Iron Man Arc yeah
what's great about season two is that
they were able to map it out it was so
that moment we didn't know if they match
cut or if they somehow pre-filmed
because it was a different directing
team I was like how did they do
this feel like Kate should be the one to
uh recruit because she was worked
alongside OG Avenger I mean Miss
Marvel's working along Nick side Nick
Fury Fury Captain Marvel and Captain Mor
yeah I also don't think there's like an
Avengers ship membership card that gets
handed over when you work with one I
think it's like a personality thing
Allison Becker 94 uh just once I want to
see Eric Voss and you two oh oh my God I
keep hitting this button refresh now
it's all lost I me it's good we got we
got some live chats super chats sorry
we'll get back look at this little sneak
preview of what's to come found it I
found it just once I want to see Eric
Voss and you two on a live stream
talking about Marvel stuff for two hours
all three oh my God doesn't he live
somewhere else he he lives in California
but like six hours away oh yeah it's uh
which is somewhere else I gave you a
give you a very jaw
answer have you seen this movie the
remake or the original neither all right
yeah yeah yeah um so here we are okay is
male Montoya thank you so
much Kendrick the reason we uh didn't
like it is because the first appearance
of a of a full fledged X-Men looked like
a cartoon and I and I also feel like in
terms of the way we got to the post
credit scene because of the movie's
Journey where especially in the I think
the last 20 minutes especially rushed
the movie just kind of felt like it was
going some people I've seen some people
have a completely different opinion that
they thought the first half hour was
rough and then it got smooth for me it
never smoothed out it just kind of got
more like rush rush rush rush and then
like when darban dies and then it's like
just like okay I guess she's dead
kingdom of the Crystal Skull style like
she dead moving on and and then like oh
I guess freaking Monica Rambo has to do
this now and then I was like well
obviously Monica Rambo is not dead and
they were like lost forever it just feel
like they rushed to get to it so I
didn't quite feel the catharsis of that
moment that I was hoping to feel
intentionally excellent sure yeah I I
know and I also thought the end credit
scene felt tonally off in some ways
because it had the emotional weight that
I wanted the rest of the movie too like
I feel like Tia paris's like delivery
and that emotional impact I was like you
guys know you got the girl from room to
be cat and Marvel maybe you could let
her act like I felt like there was so
many moments I like her more I like way
more but there was she didn't get to
have a moment of like catharsis about
acceptance she didn't get to have a
moment with with uh Camala about like
that mentorship she never got she got to
have a lot more fun and playful and and
Carol ders felt like a person but she
never got to hit like a depth and I love
that Tiana Paris did but then I was like
this post credit scene feels like what
we wanted out of this yeah yeah I felt
like there was an out like the outline
just the the
actual um script needed finessing and U
the the uh the outline was reasonably
fine I
guess Greg and Coy are both wrong sound
like some dumb asses what's funny about
this is the people
commenting what what I want everyone to
know is you can only comment if you're
subscribed I love it so if you are
commenting hate then you're
subscribed like also a movie only be
good or bad you can't have things to say
about it hey guys should Loki get recap
or will he return I really enjoyed the
Marvels but like anything else MCU that
X-Men World won't get follow through
we're getting we're getting
Xmen I don't understand this I don't
understand I I I think you're saying
like we haven't seen chuni and stuff but
I I I think that's all it's all going to
be a bigger comeback together with Kang
Dynasty and uh and Secret Wars I think I
I think it will get payoff I think the
reason we're taking this little break
like next year we only get we're going
to talk about the schedule stuff I'm
sure but uh next year we're only getting
Deadpool 3 we're getting one MCU and
then we're getting one DC uh adjacent
film it's not even DCU it's just Joker 2
and then we got um I believe Craven and
Madam Webb over at Sony but next year is
a lot lighter but then 2025 I think
that's going to be really when we see
the ship getting re rewrote um because
basically like they're re-shooting
Captain America for longer than the
entire shoot of endgame right which
makes me think it's going to be a new
movie so I feel like everything's
getting a very new coat of paint if not
a brand new ship if you want to go uh
ship a thesias on it I don't know if the
original ship will be there but I am
very curious um how much we get these
characters rapidly because of of people
feeling like why are we setting stuff up
we haven't had any delivery in a while
right right right I agree I agree thanks
for the comment there gracian may Ravari
hey Greg and Koy thank you for the Super
Chat I saw the Marvel today and I found
it fun but not great my question will we
get a plot point in the future where the
adult heroes are against the Young
Avengers assembling o Thunderbolt more
adults versus is the Young Avengers
think we might up punching
kids it's like a groan like it's like a
well because I think Thunderbolts might
but then I picture like the giant that
is David Harbor just like pummeling a
child um I don't know if that'll work
totally for Disney uh but Thunderbolts I
think might be Young Avengers and I've
talked about it a little bit and Winston
and I talked about a little bit uh this
week on Christian show but I do think
the Thunderbolts are going to be seen as
Heroes and then the reveal of them being
nefarious might come from The Young
Avengers being like you done something
wrong so I could see that element but I
don't see like I don't know how fist
fighting children will look uh optically
hey there's a way to make it cool have
you not seen the movie
kickass that's true and also Kingpin did
beat up K Kate Bishop already so I guess
it will work but she whooped his ass
yeah it's gonna be interesting but yeah
I don't know if it'll be Young Avengers
versus old Avengers but we'll
see Mike K thank you Mike K do you think
a longer run time would have ironed out
all the bugs we're talking about marbles
um do you think a longer run time would
have ironed out all the bugs or could
the story benefit from a longer Runway
filling in the 308 year gap between the
first one I absolutely think uh a longer
runtime would have helped iron out a lot
of the bugs a lot of things can be um uh
smooth like here's the
thing even in this chat I have to admit
to you guys this is probably going to
trigger some people
here whenever we talk about specifically
what we didn't like about the Marvels
we're looking for stuff to hate that was
the last comment whenever we we talk
about stuff we didn't like we we are
giving specific things about the way the
movie is executed and what people always
come back with us is it's fun that
that's it that's all that's all we get
back it's never actually well actually
like there's never an actual elaboration
to counteract what we're saying so my
point to that is is that that's really
the main thing that people can either
walk away with is like they actually had
fun with it in spite of these things
that are criticisms I'm jealous and the
thing is those
criticisms out outweighed the fun for us
that's the bottom line consensus for it
and so I'm talking about like with the
with the things iron out all the bugs I
think absolutely that was one of the
first things I said it felt like that
they condensed a a very long like they
condensed a Disney Plus show which kind
of makes sense to me cuz they have two
Disney plus characters in there they
conin a Disney Plus show into a movie
that they felt like they trimmed down
the movie then MH and I I do think a two
and a half hour like it needed time to
let things breathe sit in things and yes
the movie is yes it is fun it can be fun
and that's fantastic if you were able to
have fun with the movie but Guardians is
fun sometimes you can be distracted by
at the end of the day clearly the
movie's divisive and you have to sit in
that reality if to if we can accept that
we have criticisms with the film but we
can gladly accept that there are people
who like it and have fun with it and we
are not going to try to change your mind
about it or hate you for it you can
clearly accept well actually there's a
big other side of the population that
really has a lot of issues with this
movie for and and so that's just the
reality of the situation I also think
that if you watch a movie and you don't
like it you should look for what you
didn't like so like you have thoughts
Beyond I didn't like it I I just think
that that's like how you look get
something that you're like man this
didn't sit right with me I need to
assess it audience score the movie is a
b which is tied with eternals and um you
know Quantum Mania and B is not
something that gets a repeat viewings
and audience score two there are things
there where it's not every like you
can't solely go off I would even say
even a cinema score is not exactly
accurate nor is an audience SC you can't
tell a single indidual opinion alphab
the consens the actual word of
in real life will be a much bigger
determination for how this movie
ultimately continues to perform yeah and
even like big you know big reviewer
places like that person reviewing it had
an experience and I hope they liked it
but if like and you can't say you're
wrong it's an opinion dumbass guy yeah
side that's so stupid like it is it's a
stupid thing to say you're wrong like
it's a it's a stupid thing like to say I
don't like eggs you're wrong I I don't
like eggs it's an opin I could go you're
wrong because you liked it like that's
that's stupid as SEC now your Twitter
Robert prer saw the holdovers easily n
out of 10 definitely recommend it I
appreciate the Super Chat and the
encouragement to go watch the holdovers
what's the holdover I have no idea but I
love that you
encourage viewing experience I'll know
to check it out Ryan sner the other
thing about the the twoo is that Thor
love and thunder was met with a lot of
positive reception so people went in
with positive expectations and then when
they went to go watch the movie they
didn't like it then that audience score
shot the way the down and when a
movie specifically within fandoms like
Marvel when they get really bad reps out
the gate people going with really low
expectations so they can walk away from
it going you know what heard terrible
things but but because my expectations
were low I actually was able to walk
away more with the fun than the mess it
is this is such a repetitive cycle of
viewing experience that of course the
audience score is going to be higher and
I'm not saying if you liked it you're
wrong I'm saying this is a common thing
that happens is initial reviews and
reactions set the bar for what
expectations of audiences are usually
going to have that's the way it goes I
also think it's it's like I had a good
time with Thor the first time and then I
sat on it and I was like yeah same way
same way and like it just then I had a
new opinion that's also how opinions
work Ryan
sner uh thank you guys thank you Ryan
sner loved both this is such a pingpong
game of emotions it really is now I'm
like chill I'm just resolved into like
you know there's one
topic talking about and there's another
topic like all right go back to this
just lean on back Ryan sweer love both
Loki and the Marvels
watch was gonna be in this stream with
this chaos Loki finale this is one of my
favorite streams honestly because
there's so much fervor to it Loki finale
brought so so much emotion and beautiful
visuals the Marvel's was so much fun
eight out of 10 the what do PCS stand
for PCs made me so happy be oh post
credit scene oh posts I had to PCS made
me so happy it brought me back to my
child beast that's fantastic to hear uh
that you enjoyed it I'm happy hell yeah
there you go great you got joy out of
art dope I'm happy for you and like and
you like legit had reasons to enjoy it
and that's
dope this not hard is it I also like I'm
just so happy you had like two hours of
your life was better than two hours of
mine like I want to like this yes like I
I never understand people are like you
like everything and I'm like wouldn't
that bring me more joy and like why
that's a bad thing and now that I don't
like something it's like I'm jealous of
people that liked it because I I want
that two hours to be happy like I
probably won't watch the marbles again
for a few months and then when I watch
it if I don't like it again I've just
lost you will not hear a single person
from any of these screen screening at
the Marvel say that I I who said they
liked it to me I decided to have a
discussion with them because the last
thing I wanted to do was be like let me
tell you why I didn't to ruin to ruin it
for them like I would not want to take
that away from anyone no if you choose
to click on a video where the thumbnail
clearly shows I didn't like it that's on
you but that other than that yeah I'm
not going to go to someone and actually
say hit every comment and say enjoy it
or like did like I want to encourage
yeah I sound so stupid for encouraging
things Jay Jay thank you Jay thanks Greg
for lowering my already low expectations
so I could somewhat enjoy it felt like a
Disney chall that's what we were just
talking about and I think a lot of
people actually have that experience
where when when some a lot of times when
something is
loved a lot of you'll see the other Camp
come out even Spider-Man no way home is
now getting is like wave of for
some reason it popular it's the way it
goes it's the way it goes and then if
something is uh
disliked the Defenders come out it's the
way Cy it's the cycle of of the way
things are and it's so sometimes I wish
I was on that opposite side often where
I can where that way it happened to me
the first time I watched Justice League
it was so hated that when I first
watched it I was like yeah movie's so
messy but I I ended up having fun
because everyone said it was so
terrible and like there there's a couple
scenes in there there's just enough
little moments that I'm like this was
fun cuz it's like we're Phil really bad
for thas wife she's really great actress
Marvel's fine if they learn from this
yeah sure and they're clearly learning
they're delaying things they're remaking
things they're reshaping things they are
they listen and that's why I like the
studio yeah definitely Izzy JoJo thank
you so much my friend took a Saturday
off whoa of work and I finally got to be
here love love you guys oh thank you
Izzy I'm glad you could spend your
Saturday with us thank you so much
Marvel was not worse than morvus I
thought it was you did legit I I had a
better time watching morvus because I
was like what is happening all we
disagree on this and there were
passionate performances like I loved
what Matt brought to morbi I love Matt
yeah and like that there was more
moments for me that's so funny I've
watched morus three times wow I will
probably watch Marvels one more time
that is an honest
take you're wrong I'm wrong your
feelings are invalid I don't matter as a
person you don't matter as a person
everything is an objective not
subjective experience correct correct
Lloyd templos thank you
Lloyd I liked it I think it's a fun
humorous movies at times a little too
much like the singing But like Coy said
I think it's just not what Marvel needs
right now
yeah I mean I think a divisive like the
thing is Marvel Marvel needs a movie
what's sad about the Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 conversation uh to me is that
that movie was excellent the another
thing I don't subscribe to is this is
this thing that we ride the Marvel hate
train when we literally love the
out of Guardians 3 also eternals and you
really well you defended it some you
defended at some you were you weren't
like it's an F yeah no I think eternals
is better than this oh my God by a lot
but like when everyone was hating on
eternals I was out there in the streets
I to the point I would still weirdly I
would probably still rewatch marbles
over honestly I probably would like
because that's to me I'm like yeah if
I'm going to put something on Disney
plus I'm like probably more see I don't
watch blindly anything I don't have that
button like I think reality TV is like
cancer um but the the sad part about
Guardians 3 to me is is that um for some
reason a lot of people just just act
like yeah but that's different because
it's James gun it's James Gun movie like
it's the Marvel movie in the Marvel
Universe still a Marvel Cinematic
Universe movie so people are just
looking for reasons to have their
narrative be true they're like it's been
for a while they F narrative
reasons and I think there's some
hilarious moments in that film as well
and I really I really did love it I did
uh I did love uh Guardians 3 Robert prer
thank you so much for saying this people
can't even agree to you're actually
friends of this person I keep seeing
this Tyron Magnus name how am I doing a
Tyrone Magnus impression like what is
this guy's thing so I can understand
because I just like know he's not great
I don't know him uh I mean I don't
really know how to describe what Tyrone
is like I haven't really watched much of
Tyrone's videos lately I just keep
seeing his name in reference to me I the
only thing I could talk about is the
conversation that I know he is often
associated with but I can't speak on the
way how like you spoke about nerd rodic
and the I thumbnails I was like I was
the the the the conversation he's around
but I don't know neurotics videos and
like Tyrone I think is a little bit
more um he has kind of lumped more into
like kind of the nerdic got it okay so
that's that's that's that person trying
to say that yeah but uh I don't know I
mean like I talk with Tyrone in person I
we get along really well still whenever
we actually talk we get along if you
guys learned anything from the last live
stream it's I don't know internet
culture I learned that legal eagle is
not a
firm Mason Korea Korea hey cuties thanks
for being my goats talk to you later
thank you Mason for uh being
understanding thank you Mason dead shot
back in the chat thank you so much for
being back here maybe he was occupied
with another thing see Guardians 3 is a
is is again a testament to that's a good
hybrid of Comedy drama of MCU producer
and letting James gun do his thing and I
think they should have let that a little
bit more De Costa maybe he that shot
maybe he was occupied with another thing
or he didn't to do the Practical
substances older talking about Kelsey
Grammar and Beast practical suit got it
the issue isn't when they change a
gender they still need to make uh the
character
interesting okay there's three different
thoughts here that I don't understand uh
was it gender change here that uh I know
feel like Kel is yeah I don't I don't
know what it's really
about okay is it about
binary maybe but binary is binary oh
maybe they're talking about like I think
kesar might be who lean Lynch is playing
in that alternate universe I thought she
was playing binary that the call her
binary binary is another character I
just don't know which one they didn't
assess who she's playing I thought they
flat out said it binary oh I mean I love
the character of binary can you guys
clarify it in the chat I'm pretty sure
they said it was binary okay yeah let us
know because I don't I don't understand
this comment I'd like to because it's a
it's a super chat so yeah uh this is
this is a whoop on my wrist it's a
biometric scanner please clarify in the
chat I'm pretty sure they said it was
binary we are prepared for this stream
we are so ready berus heral live thank
you so much um I loved Miss Marvel being
a Muslim from Jersey similar age in
family Dynamics and really enjoyed the
Marvels and I hated Thor
for yeah she's binary okay I I mean
that's what was my first thought then I
kep I'm pretty sure they I'm pretty sure
uh Beast addresses her as binary got it
okay and binary like is binary like
that's so yeah I don't think that's a
that's what confus me is like that's not
a change right right right the chat is
30 seconds behind otherwise we wouldn't
be able to keep up with the chat some
people saying that
um yeah I I uh Tad I have no interest in
talking to nerdrotic like I I have no
interest whatsoever
um I love the represent I think I think
that's some great repres I don't I know
a couple of Muslim people and not I
admittedly my circle of Muslim friends
is not sure you know where they're big
Louisiana apparently cuz they thought it
was a good no cuz the in the movie they
moved this Muslim family to Louisiana
and I'm like they don't have a mosque
there they're going to not be with their
friends they've grown up with they just
abandon all of her like what a weird
thing at the end of that movie they're
like hey your house got destroyed let's
move you entirely to Louisiana oh
interesting did you not catch that oh
yeah yeah yeah I didn't think about it
in that context she's literally the
warrior of Jersey City like she's the
protector of Jersey City that's like
let's take Spider-Man out of New York
but Camala to this time it's like I
don't understand why like that's her
thing such a weird Choice really love
him M and I love and I one thing I would
complement the Marvels too I love the
family interaction as well still
sometimes I did think the comedy on the
on the family like when they're going to
space and stuff not really being that
phased by it like they just chalk it up
into that kind of dry humor instead of
like reacting to the experience
sometimes I was like craving that a
little bit like when they're at saber
seeing this for the first time like sure
they've seen some weird the first
time you're going to space yeah yeah I
like I I do think that there should have
been some reaction like some a little
bit more but that was one of those cases
where I'm having so much fun with the
family that I'm I'm enjoying it yeah say
they they were helping Carol move to
Louisiana not them moving but didn't
they say like wouldn't this be a good
place to raise a child to her brother I
thought I thought it was them moving
they had to move them somewhere they had
no house they have the money of Shield
they can fix their or saber saber has a
space station they can fix a house in
Jersey barus heral says thank you so
much for the Super Chat my friend I
realize it's a shitty movie and what I'm
seeing is horrible but it was still for
some reason a good time for me oh that's
a great feeling to have that is I
there's plenty of movies that I like
that everyone hates like I'm trying to
think of any but there's definitely
movies that every like eternals I
love West big fan we do it at at karaoke
a lot love w w West uh cry I already
said it was a yelling at me a terrible
film and I love it yeah I kind of like
after Earth whoa yeah that's a terrible
film oh wow that's impressive that's
actually like I'm a big fan of SWAT I
don't know if that's still like loved or
hated but swats my jam that's can't be
fun yeah yeah yeah Cameron cordoni
I think Loki actually outsmarted he who
remains because I don't think he who
remains actually thought Loki would
destroy the loom do you guys think they
we use Loki on future MCU films I think
what we brought up earlier was that we
think uh Loki will probably come back
via Avengers Secret Wars and will be the
one to recruit Avengers across the
Multiverse to assemble to fight against
the bigger threat I was corrected I'm so
sorry it was Carol moving because it was
Carol's things and then her she took the
one bowl it was Carol moving in her
house I apologize for my lack of media
literacy there that was my bad I was I
was already so removed um Punisher war
zone is a great example yes yeah yeah I
actually haven't seen that one the only
super oh my God what a blast so hated
and then I watched it I was like this
movie is so F so few superh movies
haven't seen yeah that one felt like
intentional in its Camp to me you know
that's fun let me answer this too I'm so
sorry for ignoring it for a second uh I
don't have a thing for bads I got to do
yeah uh I think Loki will maybe get used
in secret or but I really it seems like
Tom hson is done with the character and
done with contract's up I think he's out
I think it's a beautiful swan song to
the character I would prefer he not come
back if he does I think secret warri is
the best
spot and also I do think Kang is still
in control I think that Kang wanted Loki
to do exactly what he did because think
about a time conquerer if Loki is
wielding all of those different time
streams and encourag them to grow and
literally like he's green aying that's
more things for Kang to conquer I think
all of this was Kang watching over and
making it happen I think he wanted Loki
to do it exactly what he did from the
beginning Greg and I kept talking about
how it felt like K was manipulating the
whole thing I think to this end Kang is
still in
control you know we always felt like
that there was a
voyerism you've had only so many
specifics SC you got you're GNA have to
tell that to a lot of people Muhammed
yeah good luck you're going to tell that
to so many people you're all just
clueless and I just know cuz it's fun
yeah till the Swinton new on three words
as the ancient one is a good
example yeah that's a good example
that's for sure tell us not enough his I
don't of what I don't know I'm trying to
find his previous comment to see what
they talking one that had a problem with
like a gender thing was he T was he the
one with the binary thing oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah
that's till example of of gender
swapping being bad um that's a good
example of gender swapping being good
yeah I thought I thought she was great
yeah I thought she brought so much
gravitas and like I am not anywhere near
married to uh the the anent one in the
comics though so yeah I also like I know
the an one very well in the comics I
thought till this went so weird on
ethereal she fitted like she's so like
enigmatic she's like Bowie
man the only one I think be better would
be
Bowie
tm1 oh my God Kamal I mean uh Kamala KH
Kam KH tm1 thank you so much after the
Loki finale cements itself as my
favorite MCU show and the character Arc
of Loki is
incredible yeah no I mean for for a long
time I've said W division is my favorite
but I I I do believe Loki has replaced
that spot and bumped One Division at
number two that's also due to my
recently found sexism against the Marvel
of course of course let's not forget the
first word in Wanda vision is Wanda
Wanda yeah I used to call it vision for
the longest time he just and then they
announced the white Vision show and he's
like well that seems racist uh can't
like Vision more than white Vision uh
but I think uh Loki season one has
always been my favorite uh because I
didn't think W division stuck The
Landing I really I was really bothered
by the thing of like ship of thesis
metaphor turning into punching it really
felt like they had this deliberate
intentional ponderousness and then they
were like but we got to end it like a
Marvel show so for me W division has
always been uh number two in shows but
Loki season 2 now now the gap between
Loki and Juan division is a little bit
bigger like I think Juan division is my
number seven uh Marvel property of all
time of the 45 properties but Loki's I
think like number four or
five let's see here so I
agree
Oliver Olivier Hamlin good afternoon
jents use this donation for Shots
tonight thank you I commend the way you
handle so much negativity stay true to
your opinions that is what the true
followers are here for enjoy the day I
appreciate that very much so I mean the
most we can do is be true to ourselves
like when the screening was done for for
the Marvels most people were were around
really uh I would say most people around
us really liked it yeah and I had to
stick true to how I felt about the movie
regardless of it dead reckoning part one
we had to be honest with ourselves we we
felt that felt betrayal so that's the
that's the odd part about it when you
know when you're accused of plating to a
crowd when I'm like I was at the crowd I
could tell wasn't a popular opinion and
it's even it's even harder when as soon
as you vary from your opinion of my
opinion I'm called all sorts of mean
names cuz it's like I you want my
opinion like why are you here uh but
thank you for this because uh negativity
sucks um I don't think people understand
what opinions are no it just I like I
said and thank you seriously uh because
like I I like had literally two of the
best days of my professional career and
I woke up today jubilant I usually wake
up cranky I'm one of those people that
doesn't sleep well I usually wake up a
little nauseous I woke up this morning
and I literally was tweeting about how
happy I was and I knew hanging over me
at noon was a live stream with the
internet and here I am just
dealing with the internet so thank you
for the kind I felt the same way brother
and here we are cuz we are men of our
word let's feed around through some of
these right
here Greg watchs it tesing so he's just
trying the negative stuff out th% man
yeah bro D it dude you do sound like the
DMV you
place I don't want to be and people I
don't want to deal with no Cy Co oh I
mean you're a subscriber I must worship
your opinion you do sound like you're
plating though plating plating what I
don't know I've had I've had nothing but
people coming at me in this stream
telling me how much they really love
this movie what am I flanking I'm very
happy what am I
flanking again I I just man they're
rewatching this is going to be
interesting I'm ready for the comments
shot the review before any social media
embargo was lifted how am I going to
follow anyone's opinion about the movie
True it doesn't make we didn't know
except the people around us I no idea
what people actually said about the film
because they weren't allowed to release
it
yet yeah yeah yeah hey that's logic
don't bring that here don't do that
Jesus Christ time as we've learned can
be Trav some logic it's logic you're
missing out on
here I have to call you on it I have to
I appreciate you being a subscriber and
being able to be here in the chat I
appreciate it but man you got to really
realize when you're being logical about
a statement Jayo that's fair that's fair
thank you there's 1300 people and I'm
focusing on one I'm focusing on like
five the gamer
MJ hey man people are staying that's
cool some people like my rage it's we're
plating the negativity to keep people
streaming it's working working we got to
put Brie Larson and red ey we need to
make sure there's yellow outlines around
angry Brie Larson
candids G MJ thank you for being here
thank you for the streamlabs
contribution hey guys can't stay I
haven't seen the Marvel's I see it
tomorrow but I love the content that
Loki finale was phenomenal um oh wait a
minute I need to adjust this here on the
actual where we
at sorry uh say the best and favorite
for me were my favorite used to be
moonnight is Loki the time Stone now
fascinating question oh one uh Justin
and Aaron also worked on moonnight so
you're fans of them which makes me happy
um I do think the reason the time stone
is green is now Canon to be Loki I
obviously think that when they you know
wrote it all those years ago that
obviously wasn't the plan but I do think
that has now been established which I
adore I think that's so genius so clever
I think it worked out very very well um
I honestly think we might get something
big and Cosmic out out of the the
reality Gem and now other gems like I'm
wondering if they're going to do
anything with Wanda being so red I'm
very curious if that starts a trend of
like this big Power we discover in uh
Secret Wars no totally man also Marley
Morgan said I think you guys are arguing
with 12y olds and we might be which is
much like adult punching young Avent
yeah we don't know before you comment
tell us your reach please let us know if
you're an adult is this flip T
appropriate assault um got a couple
couple comments here first one you can't
see it on the screen it says still loves
John let's go right here love John here
he is Muhammad you have earned
yourself here's what happens when you're
a when you're this guy bye that was
enough that was we tried we let like we
let let you have you have it you don't
understand you're a logical and
now you can't reply haahaha but you can
hear me calling you an A logical moral
this feels nice I like the power can't
reply now we're we're lowy that's the
best on we can't leave our chairs but we
sure can make people
quiet yes the power of how really
argue take that run away and I hope we
just did I hope he was 12 because that'd
be way
funnier we we reached this point in the
street it's happened every time it's an
hour and a half income we've gotten slap
Happy God we need to just become like
those other channels who would make so
much who only get the
crowd that that agrees with them who
only gets the crowd where we got a
critical Drinker crowd yeah and I'll say
I'll say while we don't have a an
audience that's generally like critical
Drinker audience I there's a lot of
critical Drinker videos I actually do
enjoy I did a show Once I I have I have
um I've never seen an neurotic video I
don't think you critical Drinker though
yeah I know he can be very divisive and
maybe there's a lot of people not happy
with me saying
but there are some videos I've seen from
I'm like you know what that is a that
that I I actually really respected his
take on this
one cl Doran hi can't watch Marvel until
Tuesday cuz Recons so I'll check in
later for Loki and new stuff but for me
Cat Marvel was also a divided film and I
enjoyed it so the second film has a m
story but there are some funny moments
and fun interactions I think I'll still
enjoy this one I hope so too as for Loki
it was very good probably a better
isolated show but for me one division is
still the best MC show just cuz it did
more for the old overall universe as of
now but by King Dynasty that may change
it might change it might change I mean
it's kind of crazy it is we don't I just
realized just put this together right
the now in this moment epiphany
epiphany is that is that um uh W
Division and Loki were the first MCU
Disney Plus shows and then this week we
got the followup to W Division and the
followup to Loki season 1 took two years
that's a really good point though that's
actually pretty nuts yeah I'm like oh
you know there's actually part of me
that respects a little bit more the
first two
characters I know Multiverse Man kids
did technically but like the first who
leads oh wait a minute yeah that's right
there was there was Multiverse totally
forgot about
that totally play I literally made that
same mistake we actually came back I
made that mistake this week totally
messed that up but but in terms of
Monica Ram in terms of Monica Rambo
coming back yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
all righty here we go here we
go we got the comments on screen so
everyone knows where we're responding to
putting chapters in is going to be a
nightmare oh yeah have we had a recent
chapter dude I lost track by the
emotional intake chapter nine emotional
intake it's very important to not say
something that can easily be clipped and
take out of context like what I just
said right there yep there you're done
you're turn it's been a
pleasure hey no I agree like sometimes
there's things about critical Drinker
that I can understand I can understand
not saying like I agree with everything
the guy does I'm saying there's been
some videos to where I'm like hey that's
not a bad video I
person but I say sometimes there's a
video that pops up for I'm like oh I
decided to listen to it and you know
what yeah actually enjoyed that one
mhm all right just clarify a little bit
oh they CP the first part don't worry
that grey oh yeah this is um the second
uh stream in a row where I've been here
after post-working out and not
[Music]
showering I don't think Kate's gonna
lead the young Avengers I'll answer that
while I'm loading the latest uh best re
CH ever thank you Brin uh I don't think
I think I think it would be what be what
about like the Cala law and all that you
know I feel like young I feel like
that's coming and I feel like she also
like co-led the Champions which is uh
definitely a young team that I think
they're going to mirror a bit in the
Young Avengers story I think it's be
probably more Disney plus uh oriented
because they had have so many characters
so I do think it's going to be like a
Champions Young Avengers Vibe and that's
definitely uh
Cala Jed McKay's moonight run is amazing
ali uh I've been very much enjoying the
the other fist of konu element and and
the vampire stuff it's very good I don't
know if they need to recast Jonathan
Majors man I'll say though I thought he
was great this seon it really
was why is everything oh my God he's
incredible why is everything awoke
except Five Nights at Freddy's excuse me
uh Five Nights at Freddy's has a woman
in it which clearly implies there was a
woman in there also there were animals
of different colors all hanging out
which clearly bothers people like
you check yourself uh no no no no I I I
think
he's oh I read it in a different a
different tone
I I read it in why do people say that oh
I think he's just saying or is he say oh
he said why is Night at Freddy's and I
was like well that's the problem with
text in general is you have like
tonality things true um where you're
like I'm not exactly
sure if they mean it this way I think
it's where we left off Jay Fernandez Jay
Fernandez thank you so much I completely
understand your opinion honestly this is
a stream to be remembered for the book
store
Holy balls it's been an emotional
punching bag today godamn I haven't
drank yet November I was already
planning on having a beer tonight uh
because I accomplished many life goals
with this week's work but now there will
be more than a beer thanks in part to
Olivier because when people say hey this
is for drinks I take their word and I a
man of mine shots will be bought son of
a
what just happened we're not
filming Sunday
which just happened here was the best at
movie fight speed thanks Curtis good to
see you he was that's how I first
discovered we uh we did one of the last
movie fights ever with uh with with
homie Tony Uh I rewatched that recently
oh I understand what just happened here
hold on I'm hitting the I hit the wrong
button have you guys read astonishing
X-Men number one I think is what it said
I love the astonishing X-Men run
interact with the chat best time to
interact with the chat is when Greg has
hit a technical error VOD smoothie I do
love a VOD the stream here bit more of a
tequila vodka absence man than vodka but
I do love vodka with berries uh Justin
and Aaron should do more moonnight I
think they should
do the gang Dynasty uh and not not
anything I think they should literally
do Daredevil and pop over to being the
new uh Russo brothers because those guys
are very talented uh Godzilla interviews
amazing co ah thank you thank you thank
you that means so much to me I was that
like literally next to the K Reeves Hall
h panel I think the Godzilla premiere
was the most nervous I've ever been
because it was not just uh a property
that means the world to me it was not
just me being like an American
ambassador for Tojo but it was also me
doing my first ever live translated
interview where they only spoke Japanese
I only spoke English and the two
translators had to in real time
translate me and then their response so
it means I had to keep track of how fast
they spoke how fast the translator spoke
how much the audience reacted and like
keep it moving so it was very hard so I
very much appreciate that yeah man I
heard you did a great job your brother
was there I got to see him it was like a
really cool thing to run in thank God I
wasn't there then that's what I'll say
mid movie Godzilla versus Kong you
watching you watching jabby I'm learning
some I'm learning stuff in real
time huh I will not promote CIP Pals and
cin
Desi I'm back to being in a good mood
thanks Aisha I appreciate it nice seeing
your face here again I've entered koi
terrain we're switching J Fernandez I
completely understand and respect your
opinion personally seeing Beast like
that no I know how you're saying it
personally see Beast like that makes me
feel more relief cuz I was nervous of
how would Marvel would do F4 the thing
oh yeah no it's not on that level my God
no no the thing okay yeah if they if it
was a completely new
beast and then Beast show if it was a
completely new beast and then there was
CGI I trust me not one part of me Pro I
would have been like I wish it was
practical but what are you get do but
instead it's a downgrade we sawed that's
the part of it because when I first
heard his voice I was like oh oh man
yeah it
was yeah it really bothers me yeah and
you know and and I I do have a bias
because one random profession that I
happen to know people in is the makeup
effects profession I also am an advocate
for pral effects and know people in it
so I totally agree it's it's like the
like of profession I I have no actual
dealings in myself yeah but I just know
so much about the world and I understand
the dismay when it's like this could
have been done practical like there was
an argument for
Thanos and that was one I actually kind
of defended a little bit where I was
like well yeah it would have been cooler
practical
absolutely uh but you know to get they
did a mix though on the first one dam
was yeah yeah but to get the Josh M
performance when they're fighting Iron
Man he's like towering over Robert
Downey Jr uh like that's a little bit
different yeah the t-rexx cannot be made
full prac exactly versus versus uh this
situation anyway but no I mean hey hey
I'm I'm happy for you brother for you
agreed I'm stoked every I just also all
of this aside at the end of the day and
this I I say from the bottom of my heart
whether or not I like the movie or not
whether or not Greg liked the movie or
not there are hundreds of people per
hour discovering Malon for the first
time there are hundreds of people per
hour picking up a comic book or at least
acknowledging them if they're not
picking them up they know more and there
are people right now again talking about
the X-Men which is something that I have
loved since I was two years old and so I
don't I all of my personal issues with
the film I so glad it exists and I'm so
glad Beast is is in the conversation
again so please understand that I will
be critical because I'm trying to have
media literacy conveyed to the people
but at the the same time the X-Men is
always going to be exciting I just wish
he looked like Beast
sure Allison Becker 94 thank you so much
they have no life or job don't pay
attention to them see he wants he wants
to be mad at woke stuff see five nights
yeah so I was I had the right tone I
just wanted to correct the other sarcasm
sure sure interesting you're here we're
not the channel but thanks for
subscribing you guys are amazing imagine
hating people because people disagree
with you embarrassing hey man I you know
it's the world we live in it's part of
the joke job of being uh when you do
anything that is from a critical
standpoint or an opinionated
standpoint it comes with the territory
you know I used to host uh okay you guys
that is a funny disagreeing
comment I got to I got to say that's a
funny disagree comment e leopard it's
okay you guys didn't like the movie no
one is right all the time that that
classy that is so condescending that's
so I that was funny really funny uh much
love Jacob uh was say was last me how
dare you yeah how dare you uh oh oh oh
uh yeah I was going to say I I started
hosting with uh late phase one early
Phase 2 Marvel and there was so much
less animosity and there was so much
less like stupidity on the Internet
space about Comics then sure I don't
think I could do this now if I'd started
then but it is part of the job to deal
with Dumb and like I think that's why
you have to get to a certain point where
like you can go like okay this is the
job I've got to inor and like a lot of
it is uring I will say too uh Sam spring
I love you Greg I love you Sam spring
thank you I what I love is about Amani's
experience that she's been having
recently is that there's so many people
who did not watch Miss Marvel so I
saying hundreds of people discovering
Miss Marvel right who don't like the
movie
Marvels but they they but then they'll
say but I thought Aman valani was great
mhm I am seeing that happen so much if
this is a trailer that speaks so much
volumes to just how great she is because
even people who don't like the movie are
like but this is my first time seeing uh
Kamala KH and Amal valani she's
excellent yeah I think that is amazing
it's a commercial for this Marvel that's
amazing amazing yeah it's really
the power of Kamala Khan getting
discovered which is great and and
hopefully they pick up her comics
because she's such a consistent run
there are no valid criticisms we've
given give valid opinions to why the
movie is great other than just saying
it's fun it's still the same guy just
still that same 12-year-old that likes
guns just say it just just really list
it out really just detail it out just
let us know break it down uh Co did you
hear the creative mind be and the bear
riding Thunderbolts what the bear team
is riding Thunderbolts I did not know
that thank you that just made my day
better uh I was a little worried about
the Thunderbolts uh now I'm less worried
because the bear is one of the best TV
shows of all time thank you yeah Jackie
Mason just wanted to send thank you
Jackie just wanted to send you guys some
love thank you Jackie love watching and
listening to real Rejects and kcast hey
Coast getting some love I never no
because it's just me yelling into the
void thank you Jackie thank you Jackie
Mason my podcast is a weird thing
because I'm so used to the internet that
I'm like so used to the visual element
it feels like I'm just talking to myself
it's so crazy to be on a
podcast let's see here Alvin ever it
thank you so much um thank you for a
really generous Super Chat uh I liked it
I felt the emotional moments the cons
are great not all villains need to be
complicated I thought darb Ben was good
personally I I really felt like I could
feel the intention of what they were
going for for nuance but it tonally
registered as a bit flat for me I could
see the intention though for darb Ben of
like she's not just a straightforward
villain she's got the history yeah yeah
didn't land like everything else yeah
that I could see the intention for it
but whenever they cut back to after like
wacky moment it felt very similar to but
on a kind of like Ronin the accuser when
they would cut back to Ronin and
Guardians we like fun fun now let's just
try to like righteous Vengeance generic
serious tone about this character yeah
it's really weird to balance that yes
that was the part of it that I again
like I said a lot of it comes down to
how the execution of like I I like I
actually really liked the the um I I
actually would I could speedread I just
read yours JT yeah I mean or you could
just like list a couple points at all
yeah I mean that would help also cry
thank you yeah just a couple points and
the coast love makes me happy you can
listen to Coast on anywhere you cast
your pods so um the what were we just
talking about uh the Nuance of the
villain Durban uh oh yeah the flashback
I thought was so intriguing of and then
it was like like ANL skit though of like
like it just felt like I don't know but
you see that was another thing too where
like I thought the flashback was was a
great thing to explore to set up to show
like the the gray to this like oh Kam uh
Miss Captain Marvel thought she was
doing something right but she actually
caused a lot of damage and harm and then
she has like the thing where she does a
lamented to like Monica Rambo and Iman
volani as you know privy to the
conversation uh when she's when she's uh
talking about it and again it it was
just sort of just a few passing lines
about it when this should have been a
weight that was really simmered in and
dealt with throughout of to really home
um zero in on her journey you know and I
feel like that character could have had
that if they' again a little bit more
runtime like we talked about earlier
it's just passing through it's
like pass through pass through pass
through just having it there is not
enough no feeling it is what you get out
of the movie ackn acknowledging
something and feeling something are
different it's like if there's a really
bad song and you're like what are you
talking about there's a guitar and
there's a bass there and there's
lyrics is singing so what are you
talking about no but the way the song is
done yeah which is why movies are movies
levels of good sure they had a thing
there yeah but I didn't feel that feel
yeah agreed yeah yeah
yeah
um but hey like being able to be
forgiving on it even like yeah I wasn't
that great of a Villain Like sure that's
fine like I think the performer is not
bad I I forget her name uh but I don't I
I don't think she's bad uh it was really
and again I'm like I don't even like
look at it I'm like I'm not I can't
really comment on the writing um Aman's
great the Young Avengers Xmen and bider
make me excited for the future happy to
hear that hell
yeah a happy Hogan is a SI who's winning
in a fight Roxy or Tera much love
you know tera's a little bit more
medic
however however roxxy's from
Boston and I go I'm gonna go Roxy I mean
tera's great but roxxy's Scrappy
man I think Roxy's much more
confrontational to I think Roxy would
fight till she's burger like Roxy would
fight until like she couldn't stand
she's like Invincible think so like the
character Invincible I think she would
literally fight until she was Burger
she's like so Scrappy that's a fair
point that's a fair point point I
wouldn't M
Roxy um I agree ebony leopard some it's
not a a Shand isn't bad sometimes it's
not about it's about the quality of the
execution it's not about length you know
it's about girth it's about what the
story requires if you are jam packing
three completely different story lines
into one movie not to mention Nick Fury
storyline what happened to his wife by
the way what happened to him having any
sort of
PTSD I really had a rough time but than
are great up here in space it's not it's
not about make a long movie you can make
a tight 90minut film if you wanted to
it's about what does this the story you
are telling does the runtime need to be
longer for the scenes to be properly ex
it felt like there was one fully fleshed
out character in the three they had one
comedic character in Kamala they had one
uh a Pome character in Carol and they
had one scientific strong character in
uh in Monica and they would basically
use each one of them in that scene to
make a character
they out weight other than knowing the
information did you really care about
the people at Hala probably not did you
really care about the singing Planet
when the when they were being attacked
or were you just kind of keeping up with
the information as it kept going I was
physically uncomfortable you know uh
like that's kind of like my point with
it is do did you really feel like Stakes
n all things be your father and like can
it be fun sure why not uh but I I'd
rather just I I think at this point in
the MCU I I which is why I said this
isn't what the MC right is it bad to ask
is it something bad to just kind of want
something that is more than just a pass
Disney Plus show yeah exactly we we
should have more we've earned more
they've earned more and that's what I
said about like this is what Marvel
needs right now and I and I man the
amount of like altright Twitter
that picked up on that is is not what I
wanted but it is what it's inevitable um
but yeah think not what we need right
now is like there's a certain
expectation of quality and then there's
people like variety making those
articles which have been yeah now that
that's been disproven so much I just
every single person that got like
commented at me that like I was making
up stuff like yeah the article literally
said after the events of the Loki finale
Kang is a must I'm like they kind of
rote him out if they need to Nick Fury
Marvel was originally supposed to
release before secret Invasion possibly
explain his character in the Marvel's
you see that's a problem with the Marvel
Marvel when you move dates around yeah
um game night j14 I personally had fun
watching the Marvels which is the main
thing I care about any thought on the
movie's plot being the same as the plot
of Spaceball suck suck suck I actually
didn't notice it till I forget some
really funny it might have been Dan Merl
who who pointed that out um I forget
someone pointed it out uh but yeah yeah
yeah uh I didn't really notice it at at
at the time um but that is kind of a
funny correlation to draw yeah that it
would come from a spoof movie of I mean
I said it felt like gu another times man
that Power Ranger scene when they like
suit up was rough for me like the the
the Lackey behind uh space prints there
was I don't know man another PL yeah
there was a there was like I like I I
would like the shots when the three of
them are on screen together hold on hold
on bullets Nation came back with this
Nuance reason it's good because 85% of
people liked it it's good did he start a
new account but literally that's wait a
minute this seems like the exact same
comment from the person who I hit High
user this guy's been in the whole time
but just love that we asked him to say
what was good and he responded with
people's statistics which makes
something good what is the general user
rating to say loved is a very
fascinating word because but also just
it doesn't matter what other people
think it matters what you think yeah it
matters what you think and we're just
here for our opinion Oh What a Sad
Little Man yeah man anyway uh I'm glad
you had fun with it game night j14 and
uh I do think bullet Nation I got a
question for you did you like Thor love
and Thunder
CU people didn't did you like love and
thunder I want I want to know we are now
doing this stream just for you yeah yeah
yeah it's come I want to run a little
experiment
here because uh according to to Ron
Tomatoes um 76% so you're wrong everyone
who doesn't like it is wrong cuz 76% of
people so it
wins that's how right this how we're
going to do this if you want to be 12
we'll be 12 yeah yeah don't challenge us
not to be immature we'll be immature all
day you want to go I'm going to I'm
going to I'm going to show you guys I
lost all together just you he become me
in the beginning of the stream I'm
trying to be mature I can't even see the
chat here's a five star review here's
Greg here's a five I I screenshotted
this I you some someone bring this up
he's ready here's a five star review
from Rotten Tomatoes for because if
you're going to use this as your
argument for why
it's 100% a winner buet Nation on the
audience score
verified I can't wait to fly throughout
the Universe in the Kingdom of Heaven
thanks to Elohim for giving us the
Passover wv.org I definitely saw that
movie five star review I'm
Sor so are we really going to take into
account that every review
there I'm having for sure a winner for
sure real I like being the for sure yeah
we for sure about
this Greg saved that for this moment I'm
just saying I'm so glad you can't solely
rely on that as your winner as your as
your thing to highlight R Tomatoes has a
show called rten Tomatoes wrong do often
it's not a reliable optic it's also
about your
opinion like you like
a right say what now what what does that
mean I don't know what it means it's an
advertisement with a five-star review
from a verified account who knows how
can we trust that that is that it's
always supposed to
be like you can't trust it I do think
the inner swapping p i something I gave
it credit for sure I it's I do like the
inner swapping Powers I that was in our
review I said that like that was that
was some of the best action and I'll say
in the living room fight scene I thought
some of the stunt work too with Monica
Ram like sometimes I noce like oh
there's actually the actors in camera
doing the fight scen with some of those
ones those are really good agreed that
was really good Nate
Saunders 2 where are we is this on
screen was awesome kind of sad that he
fear being alone thank you for the super
chat but the only way to save his
friends is to be alone for eternity I
know I I just keep thinking it must be
so boring well episode I can't help but
think about Loki just being bored it's
just such a curse oh man I can't eat I
can't go to the bathroom you don't know
if that throw thrown as a hole in it I
feel like they've been just setting up
Loki to be the most patient mofo even in
Thor Ragnarok when that joke and he's
falling through for like been falling
for however long yeah I think uh cursed
with glorious purpose is that very thing
like he's cursed to that Throne is s and
I love the set of episode five of making
him like I just want my friends to be
happy and the only way to do that is to
be cursed with glorious Pur it is so
like that is the MCU done exactly right
love it agreed Nate agreed I totally
love like wacky weird stuff that could
totally work Scott pilg versus the world
I think is a great example Rango I
with Rango so heavy um everything
everywhere at once great example where
you could do like super strange things I
thought the singing Planet way the way
it was I I think there was a a longer
version of just like segue into it that
just felt like it it was there was an
oddity to the way it was done it's kind
of hard for me to explain and the way
like there were people that I could feel
cringing oh me I was cringing at it and
again it's it's more of an emotional
reaction to something that is happening
on screen where you kind of just got
here you don't really know what it's
kind of strange that Carol's not
explaining what this planet is until
they're like right then and there that
there's this whole history with the
prince like there's something that could
and also like how there's something that
I just realize right now of how like
they they have like a throwaway joke of
when they I I actually kind of like that
joke he like he's bilingual that was a
funny joke not worth the rest but then
they don't continue to
sing also like you can do it right
because Guardians of the Galaxy ends in
a dance off yeah that's a movie you know
what I mean like that's how you they're
so weight see the cats thing was
something I was like this is I wanted to
like that worked on a bias for me
because I'm such a cat lover but that
was one of those cases where I can
actually meet some of the people too
where I can go look I get why people
don't like this scene I'm here kind of
going this is not exactly smooth and I
think it was good go flurin being
threatening to this is now the thing
that saves people and we can control
newborn furans to be able to then
swallow human being and not ingest or
digest or anything like that like that's
so Str like like you got to think about
some of the logical thought process here
that we're going to take a chance on
newborn furans to just not digest here
that they automatically just spit people
out um hell of a yeah you know
like
but as a cat lover I'm like it's
adorable what I'm looking at right now I
do like kittens I do really love cats so
yeah seeker of the Matrix what time is
it I got to check this guys two what
happened to
there got people coming my God what
happened to this oh no Gregory are we
still live I'm freaking we are
definitely live bring it back hold on a
second I chaos let me see if there's
anything moving in the live I didn't see
the live chat I can't even help I can't
help everyone chaos guys cats and dogs
living together I found it he's on
Twitter I'm back I don't know what's
happening stream is taking the wind out
of me right now he is emotionally
distraught thank you appreciate it thank
you I can do this all day except till
till 3 we got a heart out at 3:30 so I
got to stop the supers at some point
that's fair that's smart we got real
life to
live yeah Tori I also wanted us to
linger on the Cala being by the reality
of saving who you can but that lasted
for about 45
seconds uh did I ever think my cat would
swallow you you out after watching the
Marvels I'm just curious um I have often
looked at him when he's snuggling me and
gone if this is how I die that's okay
what are we talking about uh if my cat's
a flerkin oh the stream crashed screen
CH just posted a Marvel's ending explain
video I mean it seems pretty linear to
me uh do you think Tom Spidey will start
cracking jokes uh I think we'll get a
more jokey Spidey when he's small town
like Hometown hero uh I definitely think
that's the the the upcoming Spider-Man
Arc hopefully Tom wants to come back and
and play I know he signed on but I just
hope he wants it more like I just feel
like he's very happy like living his
golf life okay want him to be happy in
minutes we got to turn off the super
like 20 we're gonna read every Super
Chat in stream that that comes in but we
got to like stop allowing submissions 20
minutes 20 minutes 20 minut heads up CU
I have to make sure we end on time today
yep for real though a hard out in 30
minutes so we're going to speed round 10
second at no I'm just joking uh Lillian
gaw uh Jonathan major was absolutely
incredible in this uh season and his
performance I missed him as her remains
to see him back filled me with so much
joy and to see obviously I was impressed
by the difference between Victor and her
remains already but to have the two in
the same episode both being leads and
the complete difference at no point did
I I think that's the same actor it felt
like a variant because of his
performance he's Inc you you know what I
also think is really great about John no
we guess on
track remind me about Jonathan major in
a second ready Creed
Three seeker of the
Matrix oh boy oh no Loki became Atlas
was the custodian of the
Multiverse uh yeah a lot of people have
said that I mean I I think that's the
common perspective on it taking one of
your alms they're delicious they got the
little like spice on them uh she packed
me a little uh little little uh like a
snack has a girlfriend and she makes me
a little snacks um but I think that is
an interpretation I didn't think that
instinctively because I don't think of
that character very often I do think of
the god of stories as more of what he's
doing because that is a lowkey thing um
but uh it it does work narratively I
just don't think of the character at Les
very
much I complain like a little B child
yeah you little little baby you
are you're a little Cory but I got
nuts in my mouth that's right I've
joined the audience that's right you're
a now we've turned on each other
now the ultimate betrayal made it work
you be the live chat I'll be you and
we'll do it 12-year-old stream
deal with it this is what the Marvel has
wrought this is what Loki and the
Marvels has wrought the tri one hey hey
thank you trip one do you two think
there will be a Thor Team Up movie Down
the
Line it's just Thor going Loki we must
go and he's like I can't leave the
branches I control all of time if I move
from this chair you all ends do you want
to get Mom
spaghetti you know Renee Russo spaghetti
wasn't that good if Renee doesn't make
the Russo spaghetti then Odin gets angry
and you don't want to see Anthony
Hopkins angry are BL
he starts to eat people when he doesn't
have Mom spaghetti they've got to
they've got to do just a really funny
post-edit scene in The Secret Wars of
just him just like so
tired just waiting he's practically
crucified in that moment you know what I
mean um thank you lilan you're
sweetheart I appreciate that run King uh
Thor and goddess Thor if you were a guy
I would have said you're a sweetheart
too I just want to say I just woman I'm
sorry it's it's a neutral term I say
dude
hey I'm really doubling down on what I
could really Comm now that's the clip
out you just called somebody T in a live
chat throwing next up me GI and sugar
tits coming out everybody's waiting for
it R king Thor and God of stories Loki
versus maybe happy for resolute Loki
every stream goes this way we're so
serious just true and then we just
two hours hits and we're like
but yeah that's our take on it the trim
one Tyler one thank Tyler for thank you
for the Super Chat Cory read it Super
Chat Super Chat hi guys do you think
Loki is now more powerful than
characters like wanden strange do you
think Loki is the best MCU show so far
uh your last question first yes I think
it's the best MCU so far we just talked
about it earlier and I it was already
mine and now it's elevated even more I
think Loki season 2 actually elevates uh
the Loki show above a few of the movies
that it had been behind Loki season 2
cements it and I think my top like six
or five Marvel I need to redo my list
I'm probably going to post that tomorrow
and Wanda and strange uh I think Wanda
is more powerful than strange because of
the ability to control more things in
the dark hold making the dark magic a
little bit more corrupting and I think
that it's actually Doctor Strange's
morality that keeps him not as strong
which is a good thing for a hero to have
I think much like Batman won't kill
Joker will kill the thing that makes
Wanda stronger is Joker's willing to
have chaos energy the darkhold makes
Wanda more like that and thus that lack
of Innocence I think makes wand A Little
Stronger whereas Loki I think is the
strongest of all of them because if you
can rewrite the story of life itself if
you can in the comic books I explained
briefly on uh on our review there's this
thing called the then and now and the
house of ideas the house of ideas is
like in in our life in our real life it
was the Marvel Bullpen it was where
ideas came from so the house of ideas
was a thing made manifest into the
comics as a way to meta narratively talk
about creation itself Loki is the only
person that remembered going to the
house of ideas so it's like the idea
that the character of Loki remembers
meeting the writers of Marvel in an
abstract way not in a literal way but
they add that to the concepts of then
and now and so Loki with that trifec of
power is able to literally manifest
stories themselves by remembering the
then the now and the house of ideas
itself so he's able to conjure the idea
of a story and speak it and as an
ultimate orator create reality through
orating the story of his own reality so
he could conceptually overwrite Wanda
from ever existing Doctor Strange from
ever existing making him the most
powerful when I scrolling me removing
I'm a great answer you said speed read I
handled it audience score on Ron
Tomatoes right now all audience is
73% so it's still winning it's a banger
damn it damn it we need this to to get
validation we ha
everything that doesn't reflect that we
failed and that doesn't be if that isn't
our opinion oh no oh
no what' you move on to I was talking yo
richy
brush key line I think was replac with
something better hey he does stand up he
wouldn't be replacing King if he was at
the beginning of time see that's an
interesting point um see I I can see
that perspective wrong that's why you're
a cor that's why I'm a I cry
like a little baby uh I'mma cry about
being wrong I I that I totally see where
coming from I just feel for me that they
reflect each other I think the whole
show being about an Ora Boris ties into
my feelings on it but that line does
exist and that would explain those
people's take on it being a replacement
it just doesn't feel like a replacement
to me but that's a great Point dude I'm
on the same page as you man I can't see
anything can't see live chat all I see
is Rotten Tomatoes dude what do you want
me to do with this you want me read them
mild mannered comic nerd thank you mild
manner comic nerd for changing the
conversation to tab bit here we need a
little little little brother here love
you guys thanks which is scarier in a
fight Batman laughing or Spider-Man not
talking saw the Marvels love the
movie
emotions thanks for explaining Loki the
ending reminding me of Gabrielle Del's
artwork oh my God that's so beautiful to
hear I said aad beast but I totally see
Gabriel delato as well he's a genius
painter he does really stunning like
mural AR you aren't you not I mean I I
read some comments aren't you know
sometimes I open a book or seven that
said uh pretentious to oh this guy knows
how to read this literate not just
read but interpret art and enjoy it or
not and have opinions that flesh out his
feeling about it condescending uh but to
answer your question I think I think
Batman laughing because Batman laughing
means he's cracked and he's about to go
to the dark side that said Spider-Man
not talking means he might be in that
black suit and ready to throw down I
like BR you can tell if he's in a black
suit he might be upset if he's in a
black suit you know the Venom Suit s
action Venom well there's this great art
called Venom called Spider-Man Back in
Black where he puts on the black suit
because he knows he's going to throw
hands and I've always liked the idea of
him like manifesting like I've lost it
so I think it's close Spider-Man's close
but I think Batman laughing is is pretty
terrifying dude I think most people love
that post credit scene the Marvels I'm
very happy for all right guys this the
last live stream we're ever going to do
ever because of people like some of you
the four of you there's been the four of
you there's been some not the no not
even close to but just some have just
ruined my life don't even want to deal
with anybody ever again in fact I'm
going to recluse fact I'm shutting the
channel down with the internet I'm gonna
delete all my socials because of four
12y olds the no dude pH Nation 17 he
clarified oh um I don't know if that
makes me feel better or worse he should
do not it does not he still got some
years on him to understand how to
communicate no but he can drive that
makes me feel like he's more M he's too
mat he might not drive Saturday and he's
here that's true I'm like only
adults have adults we tired when you're
when you're past 27 tired I'm trying to
take a shot at a at
someone doing a good job how are you not
punching down a child well Greg I don't
know how to punch down Aid you got to
hit kids correctly dude that's the clip
out
[Laughter]
the what is what has happened great
right great Channel very informative
right where that shows up got to hit
kids correctly great Channel very
informative this feels like a solid
assessment of what we put out
here oh
man oh what are we talking about I
haven't even started drinking yet long
time Watcher here from the trip
one first time I've I've I live watch
her oh hell yeah thank you great Loki
finale I'm wondering when and where we
see rler I'm thinking of Deadpool 3
shout outs to my man heavy spoilers who
said that he thinks ravona might be
looking at Kang the Conqueror in that
scene instead of a liath because a not
high we are it is the emotion sketch
yeah oh we're definitely we're
definitely broke I'll gladly own that
right now I'm not going to try to
maintain our composure not I'm talking
down and G fuel like it's alcohol right
now yeah no it's that kind of day but
also if we were high I'd be like under
table thinking aliens are studying me
weed does not suit my brain okay so you
know would you co talking about
things all right listen everyone Focus
up are we still talking about Marvel
it's the title of the stream is Loki
here in the room with you right now okay
he thinks his Ren Slayer is looking at
King purple glow because the purple glow
and the fact of her reaction does not
seem like horrified MH cuz normally if
you're going to come into a liath who's
that close but she like can control
elath how can she control
elath do you know who liath is the big
wind boy yeah and then Loki and Sylvie
had to go through like the the
Whirlwind to enchant it something about
you're right I don't know what I was
thinking I don't know how Kang is
showing up like that but they think it
could be the the the the the pyramid one
prin the's what K is that the pyramid
one oh God what is that oh man what is
his name is this Gort mortis am mortis
bullets Nation saying this in the
comments that we can't deal with like
he's he's been out of here
disag just been in here feel bad is dise
with us and he's saiding you can't you
can't handle the difference in I love
that a 17-year-old is still in here you
can't you can't handle the differently
dude you've been you've been so upet
having defended and you're coming at us
saying that I'm actually crying out
laughter this went from like my most I
like just didn't want to
stream the of such a statement after all
of that after all that is amazing you
can't this like we're here for
like hey 85% you have a
different opinion than me I must dress
it for two
hours I I'm just so oh my God I'm just
so entertained by like that the
recurring theme of a 17-year-old Logic
on
that he'll figure it out so he's going
to be voting soon
he will be voting soon 21 he fig he'll
be electing the next president of the
United States F I'm not even going to
break it down you got you got to like
reassess oh yeah let's look at you
listen to the I might have forgot the
streamlabs we got to look at the
streamlabs really quick oh yeah the
stream laps bring it back oh guys okay
all right we being told to get back on
track thank you chat not a mortise thank
okay hold on a sec let me fix this
Joe hey you didn't even have to go to
the bathroom be confused we're confused
we haven't left these confused we're
confused chair right here me did you get
like 4 hour sleep last night too oh dude
uh maybe I think i' explain some of this
I took a melatonin and didn't sleep well
oh that's the worst feeling yes I'm a
little bit oh my God yeah we got to
catch up here everyone catch up all
right Twisted viewing thank you twisted
viewing Twisted view everyone listen
listen up listen up theion Nexus being
literal replacements for Infinity STS
Wanda reality red Loki time green King
space blue Ren entertainment power
purple someone else said a Rin SL or
taming a liath thing I'm not crazy how
can she though I don't understand leave
some of my a thoughts maybe strange for
soul en vision and Xavier from mine God
like uh some sort of Illuminati thing
with the with the the I like that idea
that earlier uh I don't know about uh
Ren Slayer because I don't know if she
has any sort of like time ability
because I feel like that's part of the
the need for Kang but I do like what
you're putting down
here
very well said because I have no idea
how to respond to that well no like the
Nexus beings would be the ones must the
gems are reflec I think Loki season 2 is
one of the best things the mcu's ever
put out one piece is real says that I
hope they use him don't worry Coy we
going to get out of here on time I hope
that if they use him again and thank you
everyone for being thank you how many we
got now we were at 1300 did our chaos
just I'm I'm betterhelp.com very
important I hope that they use him again
he's just not a character but like a
powerful entity if you know what I mean
d i get what you mean also he is the
most powerful in the MCU right now even
over cesal he's kind of become like a
Celestial of sorts he's kind of got a um
Living Tribunal meets Watcher Vibe
because he's like watching over
everything but he's also like
controlling the abstractions it's just
so cool how you watch from like Loki
episode one how they've just like
deconstructed him at his core and
they've just rebuilt him to become like
they I really feel like they earned the
trajectory to goddess stories you know
what I mean it's so special and I I want
Thor to get that in Thor five I think
like a Robert Edgar Thor five that's all
Mythic oh my God let Thor reti I think
ruining the mindset of Robert Edgars by
putting him in the M trap him in a
serious FM so can never come out again
next thing you know let AR Aster arter
to do Secret Wars he's like I love the
beyonder I'll make a tracksuit Mark Hill
then yeah let's just ruin more inde
defend Mak Avengers s uh Curtis Mason
bunch of gangsters running the Avengers
you got to find like the right fit who
knows how to cooperate with producer
mandate that's true hey guys just wanted
to hop in and say you guys are awesome
oh thanks I wish I could receive these
words right now but we're just Madness
someone in the chat uh I'm glad we get a
talk about movies and TV again yeah me
too I'm really fing
love for Marvel president you know what
vice president they got my number I I
want to help shape things good morning
man thank you Curtis Mason that really
means a lot thank you Curtis is best
thank you Curtis you're you know what
man dude I love you so much i' I'd watch
you on the toilet Ronin T thank you so
much I straight up barely barely watch
Marvel stuff but y'all are so
entertaining you think this is
entertaining I'm impressed that he has
no any idea what we're talking I I love
that we're entertaining beyond the stuff
that he doesn't watch like like how do
you even contextualize what we're
talking about we're funny are we
according to I'm not I'm quoting I'm
pretty sure we're cringe I think we've
been cringe and we've passed into the
like like day your probably start to
become cringe yeah it's true any M
yeah
delicious uh I'm hoping enough people
call you racist for not liking the
Marvels to the point where you
eventually whip out you got a black
girlfriend I don't think I'll ever so
that way that I think you should I think
right now you do it that way it looks
like you only started dating her so
you the only reason I just like delegate
our entire relationship to one thing
that's the clip being a secret
not secret is what's funny because like
I post about her all the time and people
don't like when people call me that I'm
like that be so funny it's funny to me
cuz I don't hide anything no that yeah
yeah it's been a fun week it's been a
fun week anyway
um uh the new Godzilla movie trailer
well Coy just hosted the premiere of the
Godzilla movie seen the whole thing
twice uh the new Godzilla is absolutely
incredible I have loved Godzilla since
before I can remember and I adore this
new one it's probably my favorite
monster movie it's definitely my
favorite Godzilla movie um the trailer
is just a taste what I love is it
balances the emotionality of humanity
with the off Godzilla better than I've
seen any other one do you think that oh
truly so special DN we still had over a
thousand viewers they like the madness
right after this craziness that we've
been having know my name anymore it's
just been so so triggered
why do ki keep Greg keep touching KO to
scr him on live
stream I don't know
man I missed that people keep trying to
ccel me and they can't do it just trying
to find trying to prove that you can't
now I'm a little worried my SC num I
could do anything I could touch the co
oh screw get away with this
apparently I missed like I got nerves
missing can't touch this my change is
very sensitive COI COI Philly
G we're definitely not thank you for the
super chats and stream we're not getting
monetized definitely not getting
monetized on this K said so
many certain s I'm like you son of a
you're so like just one word I
know for sure gets us demonetized word
yeah the c word man that's why whenever
we edit the boys we can't use buter yeah
because yeah like damn it man I know too
many Aussies they rub off on me Philly G
koi I hope those are harof
nuts as much as you assume we like nuts
in our Collective mouths uh they are
they are made by my lady all right let's
Okay the streamlabs I don't know how to
turn off the streamlabs donations oh no
so you know all right here's what I'm
gonna do
guys Greg is a part of the Brie Larson
hate crbd after all that talking about I
have watched so like I've defended tooth
and
nail her interview on hot ones uhhuh
she's done two love them both her she
got for Between Two Ferns when the
whole point is the celebrities are
supposed to not like being there as a
satire joke and people still hating on
her as if she has got an attitude
problem yeah when everyone else has the
exact she was just so good is that uhhuh
I think her comedy skills are actually
extremely underr very funny and I liked
her a lot in this I've said it in the
review no it doesn't matter bring I'm on
the bre man that's why you talking about
things are don't worry man dud I
I hate Shenanigans I hate all women
that's true including especially your
wife your hot black girlfriend you got
to prove you're not racist don't like
her
mhm you know what where this where we go
where was Coy janary I don't know her
name that's a good question that's fine
that's good I just call her a co wait
hold on Co is disrespectful
unprofessional for cursing at me earlier
be a man and use your words I used my
words that was your problem act like a
soft be say it to my face you're going
you got to be tough and up DM poor life
you got to be stronger excuse me I'm
choking on an element use my words is um
put a profile put a face to the profile
pick that way it looks like you have
some level of
courageousness the the most bottom tier
level of courageousness using a fake
name and no picture and also telling me
to use my words when I used by words is
a very confusing St come
on I I did say it to your face I just
only have a d as your face
yeah everyone be quiet okay we wait very
silent like can you get the live stream
back not scrolling anymore oh oh
you're right I just thought everyone was
like damn that's a really good com let's
all take it in s let's breathe in this
experience oh
boy people really take it personally
when they insult you and you insult them
back and it's my favorite thing that
people are like like like homeboy
earlier being like I can't believe you
don't understand after two hours of
typing DMB for life be well be so
well you're so
bored I'm been scrolling for a very long
[Laughter]
time I'm talking about Godzilla minus
one so sorry everyone hold on a second
we're getting there
y'all God what's
happening
mhhh okay we read that here we are okay
we we've made it glorious purpose what
is your workout plan Greg well it's
really simple oh I'll get to that
okay leave a like on this video simple
all haters leave a like on this
video Jay's Point Jay's point of view
the Pilot's called glorious purpose the
finale is also called glorious purpose
making the entire show an Ora Boris a
wellth thought out connection from the
beginning of the show to an end hey
that's a thank you and it's also really
generous Super Chat my friend uh I I
love that they did that and I also love
that science fiction was when the lines
of those realities started to blur the
titles of these episodes are are pretty
genius assessments of the whole thing
it's it's a really the writing's
topnotch which is the difference between
making something fun and well written
and something fun oh dude yeah I think
the writing was great I love the
different direction they did MH I think
um oh God you know I mean I don't want
to be recency biased I want to watch it
as a whole yeah I want to watch both
season because I'm like which one do I
like more season one or season two yeah
they both have that great finale that
elevates them Above the Rest I also
think in terms of like finale compliment
I love that Jonathan major did something
different for He Who Remain like he's so
like performative in in season one and
then and then season two you're like
lean back and he must have been like
putting up a bit of an act to get them
to do exactly wanted Charles josa much
love back to Ireland love the Tree of
Life as your logo um yeah I think that
it really established itself on every
level and the the names as part of that
yo
Jorge
horge
parida thank you for the moment of
silence that's all we needed that helps
us go along for the Super Chat
appreciate
it it's the only way do you think Loki
holding the branches is the reason the
villains and Spider-Man in no way home
go back to the universe and BR Sidelines
without causing problems to the
Multiverse Somewhere Out There Kevin
fige is reading this and so happy it is
like yes yes that's it that's it
everyone write write down write down
what he said I like this add it add it
to the that I told you from the
beginning it's so much smarter than what
we thought I've told you from the
beginning I think different multiverses
have been established that's why you
haven't seen the celestials mentioned
and stuff I think they've already
alluded that we've seen different
multiverses but I do think this allows
for things like Sony to fold in more
narratively oh absolutely Amen to that
yeah Amen to that now a good time to pee
don't leave me alone on this it's only
going to hold the tether together so
long the chaos
I'll do three more no
PE no no go okay good I'll take a shot
here I'll take a shot all right
guys it's just going to be you and I
interacting let's see what everyone wait
for to continue the super chats in a
bit I'm just going to leave this in
place that way I don't it up all
right everyone let's go to the next
comment what's up
here Miguel is losing his after
we're located Amen to that no I don't
really think as anyway hold on this
comment needs to be shown
everyone oh that person asking what my
workout routine is uh yeah my workout
routine is uh simple I weightlift three
times a week I've also been getting back
into some martial arts
Maneuvers and um I I recently got back
into running i' I've also taken up
hiking with a weighted vest but really
the main thing is the main thing that
I've been doing is I have not I've been
really working on the caloric deficit
diet which has been so hard um not as
hard actually much easier now like what
I'll do is um I mainly have like
like two high protein chicks a day I
don't eat meat so it's been really hard
and then usually I have like salmon once
a day but a lot of a lot of my big meal
my my big main meal has been like this
keto friendly tortilla with a lot of
mozzarella cheese so it's like low fat
low carb high protein that's like the
main Jam that I do but I think tonight
I'm going to treat myself to some
delicious food are you and John together
romantically I've only SE videos in the
two million no no not anymore Richard
fearing Greg you see that t time no I
got a an hour and a I need to re do a a
little rewatch of some stuff because I
need to get it all fresh in my mind and
d and I want to thank everyone who
watched the Loki finale reaction many
you guys don't know this for some reason
we just kept getting blocked um that I
started that edit at like 7:40 p.m.
didn't get it up to like 4:00 a.m. and I
was talking with other reactors they
were a lot of them were like yeah we use
like eight to 10 seconds at a time and I
was like I'm at 5 Seconds at a time
right now and we're still blocked and
then I had I was just doing all kinds of
Tricks there are times I was like like I
show I was showing people like here's
how much I'm cropping it in it was like
most of the Fage is not frame and I'm
really croing him using five seconds at
a time I'm run a d noiser on this I
don't know why we keep getting blocked y
it just would not stop seven hours of
editing to get that up and then I had
people messaging me it was like seven
hours of editing and all people say and
people call me lazy all the time I
love it yeah and and so I'm like
I'm trying to get this up man I'm just
all I'm trying to do is get this up I
don't even care about monetized at this
point it's just not even public you know
I uh I honestly can say that one I came
back to talk of John and Greg romance
and he had just been touching my scrotum
according to you so that's inappropriate
two uh Greg I know so many actors that
work like 18 hour days I know so many
producers and folks that like enure the
entertainment industry's long hours I
don't know a single person that works as
hard as Greg so uh I know that I usually
don't attack people I know Dwayne
Johnson he works slightly harder
slightly yeah he did affect the entire
pod population just by eating them all
okay slightly I mean I've only hugged
Rock I don't know him most people just
watch our video and go all he does is
just just talk sit there birday that's
all this all makes he just opens his
mouth and then he just is here to
attacking 17y olds he's just in here for
the 17year old hate all right look guys
I appreciate all the super
chats what time is it I'm trying to see
cry I'm trying to see the killer
today oh so we're I guess we're knocking
that's why I asked you all right you got
two minutes for the last of the super
chats if anyone wants to get one in
thank you so much for them um then we're
going
to stop allowing them to come and then
we're going to have to read off the rest
and try not to get distracted by the
chat's vemi as we are but we also want
to take it in so that way no one's
ignored y we want to we we care about
everyone uh they showed the the Japanese
uh cut of Godzilla minus one I had
translators which was fun AR Miss Hall
to talk about something positive for the
Marvels I really like the way the fights
were shot in the movie especially the
three versus one I just was just
crediting that I like that was actually
a really well constructed fight I didn't
said in our review where I was like
there's some really good fight moments
in there and I think that particular one
was really well done that that first one
when they're first switching really
really enjoyed that even the 31 against
the villain with the hammer at the end
like that worked for me until they like
undermined a bit by the way it landed I
think by that point I was personally
having a hard time separating myself
from the fact that I hadn't been
enjoying the movie up to that point to
just appreciate the fight um but I
wasn't at there emotionally yet until I
wasn't there emotionally yet with that
first fight so I was really able to take
that in yeah I get that and um and I
really thought that first one was really
well done and I I love that it was so
practical also Charles Joshua I actually
want to get married up married buried in
uh the oh you hear that Co is gonna get
married to hot black
girlfriend get that non racist profile
so conf
card for life I feel like it's
just and not racist her these Ed yet and
now this is actual little bit of blush
this is me squir don't know how to react
to any of this anyway uh the tree of
life means a lot to me and I talked
about uh I do want to be buried uh under
a tree uh because of how much the tree
life means to me but the UT Tree in
Ireland at the Abby outside of the Rings
of carry is such a stunning tree that it
actually changed that I want to be
buried under specifically a u tree and
then researching Celtic mythology I
found out that it is their tree of life
our tree of life and that the Celtic
warriors used to shave the bark and put
it on their um their arrows and it
actually poisons people but modern
science has made it so it actually slows
cancer cell so the tree of life itself
in our Celtic glory is the causer of the
a cause of life and death so I want to
be buried in it because its limbs fall
to the side and like make a spiral
around itself so it's Immortal in itself
almost you can't date them the same way
so I want to be buried under that very
tree that you have as your profile
picture to answer a question in the chat
I do not only think Monica Rambo has a
good butt but she has a beautiful face
as well it's also a sweetheart by Disney
the when I had to leave early she was at
the the event I was that Tiana Paris is
a Del light yeah I feel great about
being a dad I care less about the kid
but I like the way it makes me look on
social media yeah he that's kind of how
he's espousing my relationship is more
of a publicity stunt oh yeah Greg having
a baby is just for the Graham Marley oh
yeah you take the photos oh that's then
you leave that kid aside that's also how
you get Disney to stop blocking her
videos cuz you're like I've got a kid
good look I've got a baby Disney I'm
your future market so please stop
blocking stay on track only I can track
Marley Morgan I've seen people talking
about the possibility of Marvel shifting
away from Kang toward Doom does this
mean King Dynasty has risk of being
dropped are we still at least get k for
that I think that will depend on life
situations what in God's name are you
talking about science uh no I think uh
we're in to really science what I think
we're in really science have to do with
a really tricky spot and I honestly
don't know about enough about the case
because the only things I can find out
about it feel like they're very skewed
in One Direction or the other all I know
is J the major did a great job so he's
innocent yeah because acting is reality
I hope he's innocent I hope uh I hope
he's innocent for the sake of I mean him
and also that something terrible didn't
happen I'm saying I'm hoping that
something didn't happen so publicly to
someone so awful and that lives aren't
ruined more than they already are Beyond
just like fic I hope this actor whose
acting skills I like are means I also
hope someone isn't a bad person like I'm
just hoping that I hope a terrible thing
did not take place yeah yeah but that's
too that's not gonna get clicks
completely oh yeah we're not going to
buy a house off of our uh Journey depth
coverage I mean it depends like what
what is the what's the uh conversation
now I mean it depends we got to follow
we got no no we got to go against it
we're contrarians now do we hate this
potential victim we hate every where are
we at what tell us in the chat the
popular opinion and we got to go against
it we're ready I was on track I was on I
was on three line yeah me too and we
lost it okay no don't worry Co I'm going
to get us back on track where's the live
chat I'll play with this first order
business teach baby to edits you don't
have
to teach baby to edit yeah dude trust me
please that'd be amazing uh let's see
alaton Ling Jonathan Majors
did good he deserves congratulations uh
you know as an actor thank you everyone
who contribute to the super chats I had
to turn them off to make sure we end it
on time uh but you know if you want to
contribute stickers that's a very
appreciated if not don't worries we got
you here we got you here whatever that
means we got you here we got you here we
got you here you you came here we got
you to come here thank you oh God I'm
going to I can't
even Coy could be Chris Brat's brother I
actually played Chris Brat's brother in
a movie called Bride Wars I was his
little brother in uh in when he got
married to an hathway in a movie I
played his best man and little brother
yeah yeah you know so many famous he
just specifically said a castic thing
Alonzo Pete
yeah no com back Coy can you read the
Super Chat while I fix the live chat
Loki sees the pillars of Thor and the
other asgardians at the World's Fair
with morbia saying he always forgets
he's also a god only Loki for becoming
the pillar of the Multiverse glorious
purpose I had not thought of the pillar
element that is amazing and I believe
those were were they wood carvings
making it a treees that is very clever I
like that a lot he was jealous of their
statues now he is the pillar that holds
up everything great call Alonzo P that
is that is so clever I appreciate you
pointing that out I didn't I didn't pick
that Nuance up hell yeah hell yeah hell
yeah Zachary Saros Coy we canot afford
to bring you to Ireland but we can bury
you outside the Abby and weo this advice
uh the ABY of delight uh I would I hope
I'm not dying anytime soon and I
appreciate the burial RS hello Angie I'm
glad you had fun with Miss Marvel with
Marvel Miss Marvels the Marvels I'm glad
you had fun Angie that's what counts you
had fun very
important touching the scrotum Dan v900
right there that Loki finale with things
over and over reminding me of edge of
tomorrow or like Groundhog Day or any of
those time Loop movies it was a time
Loop story DMV wants to from Dakota to
fight me and he's 36 when he thinks uh
he succeeds with timely like Cruz
thinking he got to the alpha but then it
fails great finale fun fact the original
cut of Edge of Tomorrow was about three
hours and the uh original third Act was
kind of like aliens where there were a
bunch of different um mercenary Cuts
where they had a lot more going on where
it felt like there was a full set piece
and that is actually how I thought the
TVA stuff was going to end up I thought
they were going to use the TVA agents
kind of like Edge of Tomorrow I do agree
there's a lot of that and I really loved
how the editing actually John brought it
up the editing being so frenetic and
then it slowed down so you felt that
atmosphere more and I really loved the
Edge of Tomorrow editing as this editing
they both had their purpose for the
story which I
dug oh man people are asking the matter
I'm TR I'm excited for it but then I
heard it was female Le and I was like oh
man but how many women is it and who's
Mr web if you can change characters
Sexes the other way you can change them
the way more men Mr web
great bring me Mr web in his amazing PHR
Leo Vlogs do you think Loki will return
if so how this been the top question Koy
answered it in 15 seconds the only way I
think Loki should return is in the
secret Wars is some sort of all power
fenity that maybe Thor needs to come to
I think Thor and Loki is the only
resolution we haven't really had because
Thor has matured and Loki has matured a
different way but they did them on
different timelines a different Loki has
matured so I'd love to see the father
Loki forgive Thor so the father Thor
forgive Loki because I feel like that's
the only closure Loki didn't get so I
would like to see maybe the Avengers
fall and Thor need to get something from
the man who wields time itself which in
this case be his brother allowing for
that closure and I think that Thor
should actually die in secret Wars
because that would in Norse mythology
close Ragnarok and that would allow the
universe to reset which would allow for
Universe reset to allow New Avengers to
play those characters instead of
recasting through the secret Wars
element you could actually recast
through Secret Wars and Ragnarok tying
all that mythology together hold on
Coy you just lost a follower your no oh
a whole follower I disrespected him
I do look like Jesse Pigman now so
I I need to say it like I might
need to change the title of this video
If we don't figure out a way talk we new
chapter hold on chapter eight DMV
unsubscribe to me from Twitter we need
to figure out how to talk about blade
cuz I put that in the title oh we do
okay that's actually chapter Play X-Men
in Deadpool 3 oh we have so much to
talk about we kind of talked about
Deadpool 3 I feel like DMV unsubscribing
is way more important Greg no Jaden
Stevens hey oh my God here it is here it
is we found a to talk about it the thing
in the video what time are we at on the
stream I could just make sure 29 no no
it's a little bit behind what does it
mean where's the actual time where are
we who are we 2:25 225 225 okay 225 we
are going to use your Super Chat big
chapter J talk about oh yeah no oh
chapter 10 okay no I mean no I'll have
to figure this out lat there's got to be
some more you should write what 225
means you're going to
yeah know I remember Jaden Stevens hey
Co and Greg love the channel the ending
of Loki was so beautiful impactful
curious as to what you guys are looking
forward to next in the MCU well let me
tell you what I'm looking forward to
next Deadpool 3 why because what did we
we only touched on it what do you like
the Marvel's and Loki both are setting
up Deadpool 3 in a lot of ways because
it's just like as we've touched on
throughout the stream to Showcase that
we have definitely talked about about
X-Men throughout the stream is that
they're bringing in Fox Universe
characters and as we know with Deadpool
3 Fox Universe characters are coming in
and it seems like they're going to pull
from the the Days of Future Past
Universe
specifically Coy I mean what are you
thinking and please also mention uh you
know um uh what else is in that title uh
blade too and how it's all rated I can
actually tie those together for the
video okay so I think the next thing to
look forward to is obvious the next
thing that's coming out but in this case
it's my most anticipated movie period I
think Deadpool 3 is going to be
everything we wanted the Multiverse of
mandis to be but it's also going to
finally make a lot of this disperate
world more succinct so I personally
think there's going to be a beautiful
way to end the fox Universe with closure
it's going to be a Bittersweet movie
because I think a lot of people forget
and I've said this before that Deadpool
one is very somber in a lot of ways so I
think we'll get closure ending the fox
universe but some of that will trickle
on into Secret Wars so we get things
like hu Jack and all those elements but
I think what Deadpool 3 is going to
allow is one him to break the fourth
wall allowing his movies to be R-rated
because he's going to be folded over
into new universe but two when it makes
a ton of money is the only Marvel movie
next year it's going to allow blade to
have a little bit of cushion because
Blade's the next star rated film we
heard rumor from a very credible source
that it is aund million doll budget I
think that is a very good thing for a
movie that's had this rough of a
trajectory I think blade needs to be as
important as the X-Men because much like
the X-Men had helped start this Modern
Wave of superhero film 1998 was only two
years before X-Men I think blade is
really the the secret sauce to what got
Marvel to where it is today so I think
blade needs that reverence and I think
blade would allow for midnight Suns it
would allow for R-rated things like
Deadpool tvma I think Eko being tvma is
going to lead to Daredevil being tvma
it's going to lead to Blade being r r to
have more allowance I think this
restructuring that's happening right now
causing all these things to shift is
because they realize we've matured in
age so Deadpool 3 are rated when that
does well because it will do well
because it's going to be all the cameos
as you want but also with a heart of
Deadpool along with the comedy of
obviously Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman
and the Buddy cup thing is going to lead
into more R-rated content which is going
to allow more variety in the Marvel
Universe which we need and then also
bring in the through line so everything
feels connected again solving damn near
all Marvel's problems with Deadpool
3 I was replying to everyone while you
were talking I figured I was trying to
then we got a little te Wolverine I'm
Deo handling it on the playback you hope
you have the live chat working so you
can see hey we did it hope wait am I
talking about I have it on screen so you
can see you see it all right there did
it R reck and
tour do you think we'll see Loki as
Avenger Prime Coy you talked about this
earlier Coy can you talk about how Loki
Avenger Prime might potentially tie into
the Fantastic 4 uh I think they're going
to do this interesting thing I keep
hearing about Fantastic 4 where they're
going to have it on a separate timeline
first and then fold it in and I think
the way to do that is we've already seen
through Monica Rambo going literally
through SpaceTime meeting Beast that
there are universes just beyond the
realm so the end of Loki shows all those
universes which why I think Kang is
still involved in manipulating because
he wants to control more of time but I
think that basically him wielding that
is going to allow more universes to
collide with ours causing an incursion
causing Secret Wars causing them to Rebo
reboot the universe but I think in
folding them we're going to get an
already established Fantastic Four Not
An Origin in a world that fantastic for
Our Heroes personally I'd rather it be a
time setting than a place setting I
think it'd be kind of weird if they were
like I I hope the universe is very
similar ours so like a 60s set Fantastic
4 would be a lot of fun but folding that
Universe into RS you don't have to do
the traditional origin thing so I uh
think the primes are going to be
introduced in Deadpool and I think Loki
Prime is already the concept we've
established so Deadpool 3 having primes
and then bringing in multiple universes
making fantastic for a different way to
fold in a team without having to do a
full origin
movie oh my God any other things we need
to hit from the title oh no man uh don't
worry I'll figure it out not how
anything you need assignments I'm ready
uh the trip one does an extra 30 minutes
runtime fixed the Marvel's issues no
idea man it's just kind of theoretical
at that point I think it would would
have helped for sure I think I think it
would have helped uh for sure if it did
and um there's a lot of emotional weight
we wanted that could be solved in that
but if it's more fluff it wouldn't work
deep Next Generation Captain America
comes out the following year just got
delete yeah superat hey hey Coy please
focus focus U let me see this uh thank
you MCN noite uh I can tell understand
what Co I meant by this isn't what
Marvel needs right now mainly for the
editing issues however I don't feel the
moveie was so off that it I deem it bad
fleshing out the emotional moments
definitely would helped and there's some
misplaced comedy but all in all I think
it was a fun film that very much felt
like a comic book at the end of the day
it's all subjective just glad it wasn't
worse than love and thunder that's
subjective it might be worse than love
and thunder to some people um Coy I you
know Bas I really liked your comment a
lot here because I feel like this is a
really healthy way to disagree and I
think this is a really healthy way to
engage and this kind of more of the
conversation I would like to encourage
and you know just kind of thinking about
I think a lot of people associate humor
with fantastic for Koy so you know with
mnol light's comment here um and then
just kind of seeing the way how we've
had stuff like Thor love and thunder in
recent times and what are you hoping the
execution will be for Fantastic 4 and
speaking of Fantastic 4 these is rumors
of Jake Gyllenhaal being cast as as Reed
Richard that we might get the casting
announcement next week what do you think
first of all thank you for the two big
super chats very appreciated also and
more importantly thank you for
disagreeing kindly cuz it's an opinion
and I appreciate that uh but I think the
tone of Marvel's Fantastic 4 needs to be
a little different than the original Fox
Fantastic 4 who I think we're see again
I think it's going to be Marvel's first
family for a reason I think it's going
to be as much as we're getting more
mature stuff like blade and Deadpool we
don't need not rated Fantastic 4 I think
it's going to be blissfully wholesome I
also think you can have some kind of
like fish out of water elements with
them being from another Universe I think
it's going to be really interesting to
see a not angry leading male but there
is a bitterness to uh Reed Richards and
I think people assume if you're a hero
there's a kindness and I don't know if
that totally worked with Doctor Strange
it definitely worked for Tony Stark so
I'm curious what kind of flavor they're
going to get for a more embittered uh
he's just too smart he's distracted by
simpler things so I'm curious what kind
of headiness it's why I've always liked
Joseph Gordon l or Adam Driver type they
both have this thing where it's like I
got stuff to do so I think we're going
to get a very beautiful family Dynamic
where we actually get a team that is
family so I think it's going to be a
very family Centric story meaning it
doesn't need to be edgy or dark I think
Doom is going to be a very dark element
in it and that'll be a Good Ju position
of the lightness of the Fantastic family
especially with like Johnny Storm being
like a movie star kind of vibe and Reed
being a little like stop I'm trying to
do science and and Sue being like
effectively the leader of the team she's
always the driving force and then thing
being kind of a broken um you know jacn
not jacn like Beast uh like Beauty and
the Beast kind of feeling like a monster
but a heart of gold uh I think that will
be beautiful with the darkness of Doom
so I think it's going to be a family
movie which we haven't really had
something like in The Incredibles which
is obviously based
off man don't worry man doing it Dan 900
also oh Jake jenal uh I think Jake jenal
yeah yeah yeah please if Jake Gyllenhaal
was cast before he was Mysterio Perfect
Choice Jake jenal is a very talented
actor and he also has that like thing
where it feels like he's a lot smarter
than other people and sometimes it seems
like he's put off by them I I always
like Jake Gyllenhaal is one of my
favorite interviews because I could tell
in the beginning of our conversation he
was giving me sound bites because he
knew that's what would work for a big
movie and then we talked in between two
setups and I talked about like my life
and then he talked about his and then we
were like different people to each other
and then he actually gave me interview
answers but I could tell how sick he was
of press until I actually talked to him
like a person because we didn't have
time before the interview it was it was
like a different human and I see that
bit of like I'm just not interested in
doing press anymore in Reed Richards so
I think he would have been perfect I
think that a lot of people don't like
get his sarcasm there was an interview
for um that new animated movie where
someone's like you know Dennis Quade he
played your dad in that movie and he
like very sarcastic was like oh my God
and he clearly remember but the internet
doesn't understand sarcasm that's Reed
Richards to me um but with him as
Mysterio in the MCU because they
obviously have him referencing Tony
Stark it does get very convoluted even
with variant I think it would throw a
lot of people off I think he'd be a
great casting as far as like his acting
ability and his type but I don't think
it would work in a universe where he's
already
established that's a great Point dude
totally I totally got he was every word
you said totally listening Dan v900 back
at it as far as Young Avengers being
recruited I'm still shocked that wasn't
an announced film for the phase
especially when when with Ireland who i'
buy more as a recruiter with Kang if you
know you know hey Coy um do you think
that uh um that Victor timley you know
with getting the TV handbook might
become iron lad I think iron lad is a
possibility I don't know if it'll be
that variant of him because he is stuck
in a very different time obviously he
can travel later but I do think lad is
going to be a fun reveal for the Young
Avengers I do think they're still going
to play with that I don't know if we're
going to get a Young Avengers movie I
think that's why they held off I think
it will be a show with that many
characters and I think people are going
show bad movie good still especially
with the the quality influx so I think
they're holding off and announcing it so
far dude Christian unpronouncable you've
been here since like the beginning of
the stream thank you so much who's been
here since the beginning respect because
that's we've been going almost three
hours oh my God okay okay yeah D I
totally get it Joe Joe Keef loved your
Irish accent last week guys well thank
you very
much you're top of the morning to you
l
o what I normally do not approve of
putting people of people put on accents
and justest I don't mind the Irish one
as the other great Irish American Conan
Conan O'Brian says the Irish can still
be made fun of you know speaking of uh
people being made fun of some people
make fun of the Marvels but you know
what I don't want to make fun of how how
did Cala use her powers without the
Bengals no oh you son of a I'm
shutting you up no no I wanted to know
it was it was a it was it was a thing
don't you think there's something with
the mutant genene and the fact that we
got the X come on yeah but they should
have like like they should have made
that like they should have said that was
why make it up I mean obviously it was a
mutant which ties into the X-Men and
therefore it's a early Cannon to tying
to ex which is why the first appearance
of Cala was when Xavier's mentioned
first because she's obviously going to
get recruited please explain this
ending uh also the Irish thing I do
think it's funny uh I think Irish people
just have a sense of humor about
themselves uh like I think oh do you now
I do L with your potatoes and your I
think the fact that people are very very
understandably sensitive about their
race being made fun of I think it's
funny we still call it like Patty wagon
because like Irish people get arrested a
lot or like Lucky Charms is a cereal
because that's like you know it's Irish
invented you guys invented lucky charm
you invented crime and
poverty Alexander Riveria do you guys
think we will see this Loki again during
the centuries he spent learning about
physics and science did he only learn
from OB or other brilliant scientists
like fastos Kang variant Etc oh that is
very interesting maybe he did learn from
like other going Beyond just K be if he
did like interact with there should be
like a scientist Avengers te just
hanging out
doina oh yeah something like that right
how cool would that be uh I would love
to see that I think also uh Kang
traveling through time meeting other
characters would be a great to have
cameos that wouldn't feel like it was
just self-serving so I think that if you
know we do have the Kang Dynasty that is
how we'll get new characters introduced
as well as getting rid of some do you
think when Loki was time traveling um
with with the time slipping he bumped
into he bumped into Captain America
returning the infinity ston they're just
out there just wand through time he's
like hey he's like I'm not bad anymore I
went through a whole thing oh Galaxy
Geeks you've been so nice to
usek I don't know that's a great
question man that's a really great
question but the galaxy quak has been
really sweet go subscribe to Galaxy
Geeks please Jay Jay saying Koy posts a
legal eagle reaction video I do people
react to reaction video I mean sometimes
they do and I feel like you got to be
really specific if you're going to react
to a legal eagle reaction legal issues
there you know what I would like to
react to Coy this news about Captain
America for being delayed and what a
reaction having to wait for like a year
like are you know you know I would have
gone with eagle Captain America falcon I
would have gone that just do
have G you so Captain America 4 has been
delayed because it is getting an
additional six months of re shoots which
is about amount of time that endgame was
shot cuz it's terrible because we ride
the MCU hate train yeah we assuming it's
going to be bad cuz you don't get to
carry a Legacy character on into a new
character like Miles Morales cuz it
didn't work with his number one selling
game in comic books that sell more than
Peter par rush out way Captain America
for going to be very tricky because uh I
don't know with like Harrison Ford's
schedule is that wide open six months
seems like a lot but got the hospice car
he's got a he's got to fly a lot of
planes somewh yeah two is two right that
land I need help I should be flying this
Millennium Falcon uh I think that
Captain America 4E dead I would rather
it be delayed now than have it come out
and be another movie that doesn't feel
good we we don't have that much Goodwill
left in um people that love the m i I
will not ever forget the amount of
movies the MCU has given us like there's
a lot of positivity in my heart but the
narrative is so negative I don't think
they want to put out anything that
doesn't feel like their highest caliber
of work so I say delay as much as you
need to you can only release it the
first time once six months res shoots I
think is a good thing and a
blessing Deadshot back at it talking
about Dar Ben in my last super well
thank you for talking about darb Ben you
know what guys I've changed my mind
she's a fantastic villain probably my
favorite in the entire MCU oh is he
still on like you shouldn't change
people's sex in comics because that was
the same yeah wasn't Dar a male I never
cared about darb Ben enough to know
maybe dude no darb Ben I I definitely
knew who darban was especially after
watching that movie this
movie the whole time I was thinking Dar
right you know what make this movie
better that character being a guy
changed everything I think taking the
essentially Ronin the accuser yeah um
some slight changes what if there's
another male R the accuser oh yeah no I
think that was uh I think they did a
great I think scori would finally
forgive Marvel if it was a male koyi
were we we're being critical movie was
fun Jack mugh do you think there will be
another show uh or do you eeko will
be another show do you think it has
a chance to survive oh my god look Co I
can actually contribute to this I'm G
eat a little bit I think that um the uh
I think Ekko totally has of course it
has a shot man why would why would you
at least give it a shot there might be a
well Justified reason that it's all
being dumped like a big Marvel on
Disney Plus in January because maybe
that's the preferred way to watch or
maybe they yeah there's a lack of I
don't know I think trailer looked good I
think the trailer was awesome and if the
if the like sure sometimes can get a
great trailer and a movie or show
very easy to cut three minutes of good
however like you you do have the
presence of the Kingman that this seem
like it's carrying over I think there's
a lot of cool auditory visual language
that you can do with going in and out of
her perspective via the fact that she is
deaf so I think there's some really cool
things that you could actually really do
there the the violence looks like you be
I feel like regardless there's going to
be some really rewarding elements even
if not everything fires on all cylinders
what those things that won't fire on all
sers will be I don't know but at this
moment in time I will say that I've
immensely started looking forward to
this show yeah and uh I I I just hope
it's not a drag yeah I I really hope
it's good I think it'll be like sound of
metal meets like Daredevil if it's done
right sure but uh and also David Mack
created the character and the he did the
the opening closing credit to Jessica
Jones knows things I'm hoping that
visual is an element but um most of all
uh I'm excited for a day of like I I
changed my Christmas schedule so we can
do all that January 10th like I'm
literally I'm moving my schedule cuz the
trailer was that good cuz I was going to
I usually do Christmas in January I
already hired other people to be I'm not
on the channel anymore in 2024 I felt
Roxy and terara would be a better fit
experts Marley
Morgan thank you Marley if Tom if Tim
heston's done think they'll bring back
kid Loki I think they should bring Tom
in Ah that's funny because you're making
fun of his
typo uh I think kid Loki could be a
young Avenger I think it would be a fun
variant that obviously wouldn't feel
like it's as disparaging to like okay
that's clearly not Tom hson or someone
like I don't want to see a variant of of
I don't want to undermine episode six
this would be fun I don't know if it's
likely though you know what I just
realized for some random reason don't
ask me how the web of my brain works no
one should when K koi when Loki is
before he decides to go out to of the
TVA oh my God I'm forgetting all the
words of the stream and all that it's
been hours uh the when he's saying like
I know what kind of God I want to be or
whatever you know that moment yeah he's
directing these words and he says like
for you he's directing these words to to
silie yeah which is also like directing
words to
himself actualizing yeah I I don't know
how I got there know I'm like from kid
Loki my mind went to every before they
brought back kid Loki and everyone's
excited and then Loki was a woman and
then everyone got up in arms and then
I'd be like but come on there's like a
bunch of Loki variants and then my mind
went to that moment very that is a leap
that is a series of leaps uh should we
check in the live chat I know you're
going to scroll but if you want no Co
look we got a TWD contribution here okay
Tatsu oh yeah okay yeah let me get the
live is it still going I'm talking about
Anatomy drugs and Tyler Swift I don't
know what it was but it please
please I don't mean to yell at you when
the camer definition is so good look at
Greg look at the bulk on you look at the
Greg definition he's got I he talking
about Sylvia and Mobius but for the sake
of my argument uhuh I'm gonna say just
talking to Sy yeah because it feels like
it connects more to that that plot I
don't know where tww3 is from TWD that's
Co Walking Dead is it is it Taiwan
dollar no no it's The Walking Dead money
that is that is money used for the
apocalypse it is money from the
cast do you
think Norman Reus dollars appear as iron
lad and kid Loki as now Young Avengers
is finally being formed damn we just got
that question back to back that's
fascinating Taiwanese dollars uh yeah I
think they should get Jonathan major to
play IR dude uh there's a kid in Haunted
Mansion that looks just like young
Jonathan major and he has that same like
eye of this eloquence and like beautiful
speech pattern I think that kid from
hunted Mansion should play him Richard
we don't start flexing till the end of
the stream yeah that's
true end of stream oh I wasn't
flexing
end
of ours are so big Deadshot it's my
therapy okay everyone everyone let him
clarify okay or
clarify Galaxy just Twitter me let me
clarify darb Ben is gender swap but she
was still ridden bat but good actors I
totally forgot darb Ben was gender swap
that's kind of crazy I did not know for
as as huge of a fan as I am of darbin in
the comics and how I really care for
darb Ben to be brought to life
accurately hence my Bohemian outrage
towards the port take my post till s H1
it's a good gender swap I don't feel
like their gender had anything to do
with it like they don't even play Brandy
when who gets up in arms about this
movie of of like they the girl power
thing I don't really feel like there's
anything about Fe like Barbie is
significantly more about that than this
yeah and this didn't have a single like
we're doing it cuz we're girls yeah man
I don't really did any of that other
than the fact there's wom on screen I
don't feel like I did any of that that's
right I'm plating it's pretty woke to
put a woman on screen Greg that's true
that means they had to pay them when I
dollars when I saw Quinton Tarantino's
Kill Bill yeah I was like what is he
doing in Charlie's Angels I hear they
put three of them on camera I know but
then it helped to have Bill Murray oh
right Bal it out then it went o they
they
recast yeah I was woke well cuz Lucy Lou
you know obviously true white woman hell
St
McDonald so glad you guys are back doing
live streams again oh man have people
been kind yep we are too second one back
has been a laugh Riot watch the
Marvel last night had a lot of issues
with the film but the con family were
really cons cons were really good really
hard to the film much love from Scotland
I like that he saved it for the end so
you didn't do a Scottish acent you son
of a we should have known from
name McDonald mhm mhm hey hi I'm Gerard
Butler I am a low Bing citizen in the
United States of America tell me Greg
How Do You Train Your Dragon there
there's a
gorm I need men roughly 300 of them jell
P oh my God we wouldn't have forced it
in here if this is like our uh
wait this is our equalizer commentary AG
king that's nice blade thoughts joural
Pete blade thoughts okay well we talked
about the blade R rating we did good job
yeah it's in there do you want to talk
more about blade well I I what I'm
worried about is blade is that Mersa Lee
is gonna quit I'm really worried about
that I think that's next you think
that's next I don't that is terrible PR
for MCU at that point I think that's why
they're holding it and they're going to
be like Marvel's dead before the next
great thing I think they're asking Mersa
to not say it until they have someone
else my worst fear I hope I'm not I hope
I'm wrong I really really do hope I'm
Ali but I he's great he's so talented if
he does exactly his performance from
green book in man he's going to get
another
Oscar there it is it's just I was
watching Green Book I was like this is
PL they're goingon to call it blade book
it's gonna do great the darkhold blade
book uh someone should recut footage
from green book and make it look like
vampires the guy from greenbook No merel
is so good he's so good I'm just totally
joking
obviously but uh I do worry that uh I do
worry about it it's been a long time
Todd don't you leave Todd is
going to watch me on other channels but
I'm not live there or am
I Christian please don't go you've been
great you've been great three hours
Christian that's
nothing so how much time how many more
we got okay Coy we got to be we got to
have a fish what you gonna say about
what were you gonna say before I
interrupt you in my hilarious joke uh
which was it about Jessica Clemens is
hilarious what yeah of course she is oh
BL uh I do think that blade uh getting a
rewrite and getting a small budget is
going to be good but I also think
there's a current blade comic out right
now usually they line up the comics to
kind of be tonally what the movies are
going to be and this is when blade was
supposed to come out so I think this
comic was written for the intention of
new blade Watchers to go to the comic
and the comic is exceptional and the
tone they gathered is is very
interestingly um magic meet science
which we know was also their goal for
iron heart so one I think that's going
to be great for Ghost Rider midnight
Suns those things but you should also
check out the blade comic that is on
issue like three or four that's out
right now to give you that taste also
good comic in general yeah Lola
Monroy give Tom Hedon an em and give to
Hon Emmy give Tom hson Emmy I thought he
was excellent in the show I don't feel
I'm not saying he's not worthy I feel
like if there's anything these shows are
notorious for is completely let's face
it Charlie Cox and and uh my God Charlie
Cox and absolutely I would throw
Christen Ritter in there Jessica jum
yeah uh grave absolutely I I think these
performances
Danny oh yeah no Danny Ram John bural
dude actually H yeah like they deserved
they absolutely deserved Emmy
nominations and for
some that yeah the show is so
good and the ratings that was
the guys the blade comics called blade
but look for the one that's from 2023 I
think Natalie Holt's music score
absolutely deserves uh oh my gosh so
good that score deserves way more
recognition I was I I was the first time
we've done how many reactions we've
watched so many Incredible movies like
you and I we do this during the the last
like 10 minutes of that like beautiful
orchestration visually and and through
the sound was the hardest time I've ever
had being on camera like just because I
was like I'm so in this I keep
forgetting to be on because my brain is
like live in here and I was like but
make a face that doesn't look like your
scal no man you just got to talk you
just got to let us in on all the time
you got to let us in on what you're
thinking then the comments are like is
always talking I'm like where talk over
when there's dialog
I had to predict the future I haven't
seen
it CH Chomp in the microphone hey
hey a funny it's a funny hat it's a
funny hat while car got canceled that
sucks been following you guys since the
Daredevil trailer reaction back in 2015
I believe wow man I still remember that
TR it's a great TR I just wanted to say
you guys and rock um your guys
takes are very intriguing where for a by
the way congrats on the on the god God
Miller minus God God Miller oh my God
guys three godilla minus one Premier
yeah oh dude totally congratulations to
Coy thank you for being here for so long
and yeah I mean our takes are just kind
of trying to follow hey Christian harof
hey Christian harof we were just talking
about his nuts are you trying to get a
reply from me in text that I missed a
text message I'm sorry yeah um your guys
takes are very qu har has been great by
the way congrats on 100K subscribers DK
I was very proud to be part of that our
takes are very intriguing I try to copy
what Christian hardoff says and I go are
people responding well to it all right
just just replicate that he just watched
his the Marvel's review oh okay
that's what I got to say people seem to
be responding about the people
positively help them hit 100K so I was
like okay let me just say what harof is
saying he's still a shill According to
some but he also hates everyone's
opinion according to others like us I
mean that's I tell the internet GES one
day I'm going to figure out how to make
everyone happy yeah AGN King thank you
so much thank you so much are the kind
of things you're saying right now Jen
FRS hi y'all hi COI my husband was the
one who tweeted you the other
day uh F the haters I thought it
was pointing up just the haters haters
does this mean that's where they are
phase 4 five starts after Loki season 2
I love you guys or has phase one started
after Loki season 2 another reason and
people have been saying that the Kang
thing can't Loki being the beginning
remember the opening credits of Loki
season 2 episode 6 it's the Marvel in
reverse and going back to the very
beginning back to the comics back to the
origin I think it's him at the beginning
of time I know people disagree but I
think it's before phase one
personally personally and also thank
your husband for me that was very kind
anyone coming to v hot husband Jen yeah
look at him in that thumb good for you
damn good work fine cool last name too
FS
FS Kenneth Valenta well Kenneth I can
answer this question for you thank for
the Super Chat thoughts on Hope for the
new avatar the Last Time teaser from
Netflix I hope have you seen avatar the
Last
Air that's why I'm like oh my god dude I
dude great show fantastic canceled my
Netflix um why because they were the
reason the strike went like an extra
four months the strike is done and I'll
come back when stranger things is back
only worth watching avar the last s
Bender fantastic show um I think my
faith in it is um
sorry I was just reading that Christian
okay my faith in it is mainly because of
um what what one piece did granted I
haven't seen the one piece anime but by
all accounts I like I really love the
one piece show and I've heard everyone
who's like familiar with one piece
really love the adaptation and the live
action so I'm like all right good
awesome good to hear that like both
camps can be satisfied I'm hoping avatar
the Last B can do the same thing I mean
I think one Benchmark it's got it clear
that'll just make anyone happy is bam
just be better than that mni shamalan
movie you got one main bench cleared
perfect boom bar set extremely low but
as long as you get a better live AC in
that awesome I'm hoping that they
doesn't just do a direct onetoone
adaptation and does take some chances to
do some of its own things while also not
completely obliterating the brilliant
horce material but overall from the
first look I thought it was a pretty
good look and I mean everything looks
very APTA I'll say you don't get it but
there's a character called opa mhm MH
he's a bison oh he's there on the does
like talk no he doesn't oh he's cute no
that's M bison who talks oh okay got it
six leges so yeah Carl Maxi but yeah I'm
looking forward to I think was good u i
liveaction Legend of cor I would really
hope for that the world of of like
embodying like kind of that 1930s 20s
period would be awesome to see Carl Maxi
I had fun with the Marvels the actress's
relationship is fun and charming and I
love Cala being the fury of the MCU
where's Isaiah Bradley these kids they
should have just show up with all the
kids they're just hanging out in that
one room randomly hanging all the kids
were there miss to come we uh we used
your bathroom sorry Wicked and speed
show up but man that would be fun but
yeah no I think uh I think I think that
was a really fun eded credit scene and
I'm glad you had fun Carl Marx uh that
sounds like a great time Carl Max Carl
Mar sorry Greg is a Marxist
confirmed people ever actually reach
your name is k
marks oh Jesus oh amazing Vagabond of
light thank you so much love you guys
was introduced to Coy from NR oh that's
great to hear and Greg from heavy
spoilers whoa someone actually came up
out there I'm glad to have more and more
nerdy exposure really enjoy your guys as
takes oh Vagabond Del light that is so
kind to you to say well hopefully one
day new rockstars is shut down and heavy
spoilers is shut down and the only ones
we have the Monopoly we are running it
we are buying it we're consuming it like
Disney's eating Luke it's ours yeah the
reject rock stars planned the whole time
the new real spoilers but seriously
thank you it's always awesome to see if
one more discover from another Channel
it feel like it doesn't happen enough
and then when it happens you're brought
over and you fall year that's really
that's really kind you think and we lost
at least four followers today oh my God
probably more honestly I don't want to
look at the this going to be a lot of
down votes Co start off his live stream
but you uh to know oh yeah okay um
FY thank you so much would you consider
Loki being uh Nexus being now uh yeah
absolutely or something above that I
consider him almost like a Celestial I
think he's an abstraction I think he's a
an entity of story itself so beyond
Nexus being oh my God Co you're going to
watch something amazing we're gonna get
this done on time oh my God watch this
no we can we can I feel it I feel it
sorry live chat we'll get to you more
but I
gotta all right shy lunaman Knight I
didn't skip one right no okay do you
think New Avengers team will have the
follow following Captain America Kate
Bishop heang uh she what Captain Bishop
he Thor Captain Marvel kamala's Miss
Marvel's the eternals and Deadpool wow
that's a lot that's a lot of the
eternals themselves bless you the Lord
Jesus Christ bless
you
salvation Coy who do you think the new
amag teams are uh I think it's gonna be
um Captain America Doctor Strange um
shuni Captain Marvel and a member of the
eternals maybe but it didn't do as well
as I wanted it to and I think Young
Avengers will have Kamala I don't think
Deadpool will stay with a team I think
he'll bounce around I think he'll pop up
an X-Men and Avengers uh uncanny
Avengers has Deadpool and it's a blast
but I think it'll be like it'll be a
wild Cannon I think they're going to
really separate Young Avengers and
Avengers that's what I'm saying I don't
think Cala would be on Avengers uh but I
think we're GNA get um like that kind of
setup and I think She-Hulk is gonna in a
land there they really pushing um uh
what's Kam maani character name again oh
yeah my God Kingo thank you it's three
hours yes is it Kingo I think it's Kingo
I feel like he'll stick around yeah they
need a comedic relief because Marvel's
not funny enough no Jes ever I was so
happy when they used kamal's imagination
through the paper drawings like they did
in the show again that was a nice
introduction I thought it was a
brilliant introduction I think it
actually got us to like five more
minutes of Goodwill that was good that
was really great yeah I agree with that
I agree man good something I did not
point out I was too vexed by some other
things and it it clouded some of the
positives in my non-spoiler and I feel
bad about that I do
struggle Skywalker do you think Loki
will be usurped of his position in
Avengers 5 by the Council of kangs and
travel the Multiverse to assemble the
Multiverse
Avengers that is a way they could bring
him back but I I don't think Loki's
coming back I think that is a a fun
little story uh think this H I think it
I think it I think that's a great story
and I it's fun in the comics but I don't
think uh I don't think Loki and that is
a way to have Greg's idea of like first
villain gather of Avengers that Ora
Boris but um I I just want to say Ora
Boris it's fun to say but I don't think
that's the that's the
move okay okay okay okay uh I got this i
got this I appreciate all these super
chats we're going to honor all them yeah
mck no light didn't think we get an
X-Men tiin but if I had to guess I would
have thought it would have been Rogue
given her history with Captain Marvel in
the comics glad Carol still has her
powers though well they had to have some
scientific Mumbo Bumbo jargon mumbo
jumbo jargon he in order to justify I I
actually think Hank McCoy is a great
pick because it's noticeably a mutant
and it's and it's an instantaneous
register of the fox M so that way you
right away know no questions asked he's
an iconic M and the last and you could
do the math on last time you saw him was
Days of Future Past so you can kind of
put together some potential timeline P
you know I think narratively the Captain
Marvel the Rogue thing is great but I
think in a movie narrative the Beast
thing is great and I also think that he
has spent time in space he was dating
Polaris for a while he is a space mutant
so I think it works yeah no I actually
think that choice was a really smart one
on the MCU but I would have loved to see
eventually Rogan and Captain Marvel yeah
but you know you can't have any Nuance
opinions here I hate it only entirely
Stephen Thunder 90 just got here so did
Loki confirm the X MCU is 616 didn't
they say they' said it before but I
thought they said 616 which the quantum
realm yeah the quantum realm in the 616
would be you know that adjacent but the
616 is uh it's the comics I still I I
think you know what Aman valani is right
I'm sorry Kevin fogy it's Earth 19999
616 is the comics and yeah they doubled
down on it but I still think it's wrong
man you're being racist Kevin fogy yeah
totally agree Gabby P hey Gabby good to
see you it was great enjoying Loki
season 2 with you guys thanks Coy Greg
and John love you oh man it's just nice
to get some love like that thank you
Gabby it's uh you know when you put out
these videos sometimes you forget
sometimes you just forget about like
that there's some people might actually
like you and you know it's really easy
to forget that like sometimes you get a
million subscribers and only half a
million hate only half a million
hate the tribe won trip One release it
to Costa cut I don't think she edited it
I feel like uh yeah I don't know if
there is a cut for her to have enough
control to to describe what we want yeah
but you know I I would be curious I mean
even she said it herself like at the end
of the day was making a Kevin fige movie
you know yeah whereas like guns
conversation around it it's like I I
still made a James gun move within the
Marvel Universe she was making a Marvel
movie and that's why Guardians 3 feels
unique but still part of the MCU yeah
Shay Shay I enjoyed the Marvels but I
think more so because I desensitized
myself before going in accepting it
won't be top tier liquor help to oh my
God that would be so fun that's why they
got everyone drunk at or screen they did
that oh my God at our screen I've never
been to a screen like that where
everyone's so people are drinking
beforehand and everyone's like like like
Rowdy and so social and like they're all
like running around I was like man
people are so energetic before this SC
and I didn't drink like wait a second I
didn't drink any alcohol so I was just
in my seat being like when's this
thing going to start yep cuz I
got to shoot a video why Greg hates
Cinema that's why I hate Cinema because
I didn't get drunk before watching the
Marvels like lesson learned everyone
else at the Press
screening some people really love perks
at these things and I'm always like I
just want to do the thing yeah that's
true I can vouch for that go to
premieres and I'm like yeah I like
premieres cuz people are happy when's
the movie going to start I like the joy
shy lunam night thank us so much I just
don't want to have anything interfere
with having an honest take on something
but press scen are so stuffy that
interferes the other way some I feel
like premieres are even more like we
love anything that's happening
right now that sometimes they can really
cloud an honest opinion but more on that
later um MCN noite the introduction as
Rogue in Captain Marvel final film will
be a great chapter ending would deal
with temporary loss and change and to
live that would be fun if they wanted to
let Bri retire I do think uh you know
with her experience in the first film
and now this one I could see her wanting
to go and it'd be interesting to have
maybe not a a third film but maybe an
X-Men she cameos that's how Rog gets her
powers we let Bri you know live a a
normal civilian life I think that'd be a
good way to retire the character if she
wants to go uh I hope she does it
because I really like her yeah yeah I
totally agree man yeah these are all
things all true things uh want to read
the live where's the live chat no no no
no no Co don't worry I'm just got I got
I'm making a message ask to push
something Jamie Rodriguez should Young
Avengers be a D+ show or a movie well
considering a lot of them were
introduced from the Disney plus I feel
like I personally would
prefer oh my God I really don't know
because I feel like oh it be so great
for them to get like a they only need
time I think Disney plus I think you
need episodes think two hours would be I
think it's not to say it's less than I
just think you would flesh it out better
and it would be a cool thing to like see
a big big team up like that we needed
cap Iron Man and Thor movies first and
we're not going to get a true so I think
a show I think a show too that's I think
that's a fair assessment I think it's a
good efficient quality answer I
appreciate the Super
Chat Adrian Gonzalez a lot of people are
toxic there thank you for their very
generous one and hate their life so the
project they project it onto others just
know a lot of people love you guys me
being one of them well I hope you love
me as a human being and not for a
content creator cuz cuz one is good and
the other is bad and just keep being
yourself and the real people will see
that no no no no one that's true no ever
see the real me thank you Adrian
internally I am a rotting pumpkin uh but
I appreciate it so much yeah I know
there's a lot hot November toxic and hot
hot November pumpkins I I know there can
be a lot of talk but I but it's nice to
have people like you and recorder Adrian
really means a lot I was very angry at
the beginning of this chat now I'm not
so thank you oh yeah no it's because we
have become numb we are mad
with Christian unpronouncable thank you
who's been here since the beginning of
the stream I love how Loki struggled to
gain knowledge to be able to control his
time slipping reminding me of the 12th
doct that is what I was talking about
during when I kept saying reminds me of
Doctor Who is that specific episode of
Capaldi there's this crazy there's a
whole what you just said yeah like and I
was like oh there's a lot like the
Capaldi episode but that when he kept
dying oh yeah which is kind of like what
was happening it was a combination of
them both yeah cuz cuz uh it it was a
it's more like a convoluted science
where he was more like I have to become
like a badass Warrior yeah you know but
yeah that's that's exactly the the exact
thing I was thinking of when I kept
saying it during the reaction Mr Lock
thank you so much explaining how uh Loki
began time slipping with other than uh
um he who remains paved the road to it
he just starts doing it for no reason
koyi take it away be insightful I
thought it was the end of the first
season where when you killed uh he who
remains it caused like time Distortion
because he was at the end of time and
that's how he got back and when he got
back he was between times is how I
interpreted it Between Two Ferns you
does that seem accurate was there an
explanation I missed because that's
honestly what I thought and I didn't
think to think back on it I just thought
okay season two the end of season one
was he her Ms getting stabbed thus it
must be true right yeah yeah no keeping
up with everything you're saying I
totally said a things I'm just making
sure that's what I said I got the 3:30
and I had to like ask some favors to
push it move things around you know how
it goes I know it goes here we are we
said we're going to stop at three we are
I don't have a good trajectory of the
time the way how he who remains does
Hees love most about it hope he's
innocent because he's a good actor and
um I'm just going to ignore everything
else you know yeah it's the way mindset
should work totally fiction and
non-fiction blend them yeah
[Laughter]
not even going to say I was joking we're
lost I'm gonna say I'm serious the Alvin
Everett the Statue of Liberty is bronze
and still is Captain America shield this
takes place before no way home I think
it's a different Multiverse I think I
think different timelines I think it's
what the in the um Loki the Statue of
Liberty in the Marvels uh the Statue of
Liberty is is oh yes okay so I think
that's she's an different timeline I
honestly think we have different
timelines happening simultaneously and
you're going to find that out in Kang
Dynasty or Deadpool nobody believes me I
don't understand how the Multiverse Saga
would do why don't they say that though
why why try to make I think they wanted
to be why why try to make some badass
twist I feel like it just makes it
confusing because I think they want
Avengers moment they I think that's
really annoying and I I think they I
think they should cut the cut sh
think they should cut the guys what
do you think do you think it's annoying
guys put it in the chat if you think
it's annoying when you think there's oh
my God you think it's
annoying oh my God we're doing
this oh man guys Ray with a knee
yep if Kane killed Cassie in that prison
scene with Scott used time to bring her
back only to repeat her
death over and over again for her father
maybe that would have made him more
intimidating yeah there's ways he could
have made him more intimidating wait are
you implying that Kang the time
conqueror should have had some sort of
time Powers an Ant-Man that's a crazy
concept it's almost like that would have
been the character they should have used
instead of whatever they did Jonathan
major played Kang but man the writer and
director didn't I I like pton Reed a lot
and I'm sure the writers have done other
things but that that was crazy twist man
well I mean like you literally had him
manipulating people with everything but
time and I go he's in the quantum realm
which the way they like wrote to neuter
him but it just that would have been
great and it makes me wor I would have
just aged her imagine Scott who's
already lost time with his daughter
watching his daughter age before her eye
his eyes and literally feeling that time
lost already going further it's a
metaphor for time it's a metaphor for
like prison being trapped it's a
metaphor for the blip it ties everything
together and it ties to the villain
instead don't use it all good good call
Jen I really appreciate that that is
true Marvel you got my number I'll help
you're right um you know what I really
like that moment when he who remains
made fun of uh Victor timely yeah that
was
funny Victor well because the pauses it
also shows a time thing which is fine
Alvin
Everett thank you Alvin potential Young
Avengers here we go Vision Miss Marvel
Kate Bishop Cassie scar yeah scar funny
scar best haircut ever speed Wiccan
America Chavez kid Loki Harley Keener
Iron Heart tant P love ASD Heim doson
and filel I mean we do have hella
characters uh so they could do this I
think that's a bit much um but karomi
yeah I don't know if we'll have that
that any in the team but a lot of these
I do think we'll see I don't think we'll
see um I don't think we'll see a kid
Vision I think white vision is the only
place we we take Vision next if that
show still happens white
Vision Connor Ben Bros is Loki now the
one above all koi oh sorry Stephen said
I meant that it couldn't have been
before no way home I still think
timeline thing uh Loki is I don't think
he's the one above all but I do love
that that I I concept to me Stan Lee
because of all his cameos is always and
forever the one above all he's the
Creator three and a half hour run time
10900 thank you so much for you for all
of us that per this one's more
exhausting than last week because of the
emotion first hour yeah the last one I
was like this is fun but man that was
this has beeno boy last live stream this
is one for the books I we I love this
one this is a journey this is a journey
when for you for all of us that parallel
with Thor
one such complaining about the
support that they giving us I know who
do we think we are pretty much going to
takes care of all your time here yeah no
thank you guys that parallel with Thor
one where Loi said it but did it for
himself and Loki truly meant it in the
finale was amazing symmetry good word uh
I agree I really like that they've used
so much symmetry between Mobius and Loki
between Thor and Loki they set up all
those things for like long running
writing and then guy I'm just saying
they did a really good job they did a
really good job establishing so sharp
they did a really good job establishing
narrative parallels to things that were
never intended to go further they did a
really good job using seeds that weren't
planted and making them like flowers
which which I think is the beauty of the
Multiverse and the beauty of an ongoing
Universe like this the Loki is exactly
what Marvel needs look they G us an
option to just insert ads I just F just
we're that long we would just be so
funny if just like I'm G to play an ad
while we're reading donations that
people gave us more money capitalism
more money
capitalism you mean I could play ads
narrative YouTube literally suggesting
insert an ad right now focus on your
live stream and let YouTuber insert ads
for you I'll insert ads after the stream
is done I got to do it while we're live
so funny you wait
unskippable
Melvin joining late so I don't know if
thank you for the super chat buddy I
don't know if you all talked about but
Tom hson said I'm found the L season 2
is the conclusion of 14 years of his
life thoughts I mean he's not wrong it
life two different versions of Loki I'm
not I think there's ways you you can
just take it's not the end though it's
not finite you know people always say
conclusion on things but it's it is the
conclusion of this but I don't think
it's the end I think I think it is it's
not the end no man he's still young and
until he gets another role that really
financially takes care of him no oh he
is set for what just the Marvel money
you're he doesn't have Downey money
touche touche he doesn't get Downey
money he's got Disney plus money he once
I mean no you're right I wouldn't yeah
no man I don't see him coming back I
think he wants to do like stage I think
he wants to go like and he's also a dad
now an actor from theater wanting to do
stage that it's all about money he
want go be a dad about money capalm
about to insert an ad put some ad right
now put some ads
in for Loki do it for Tom Mustafa
J this is the first movie I think I
disagree with you in terms of overall
quality I enjoyed it a lot bottom line
This confirms you are sexist appreciate
the Super Chat Mustafa understands
confirms appreciate it didn't I just
hide him as did I just block him uh oh I
thought he was joking no was he I hope
so because that seems like a joke I'm
glad you enjoyed it a lot and um yes
sexism confirmed yeah it's us th% and
don't forget
racist um Christian and also ctist oh
very much so Christian
unpronouncable Infinity watch with all
the beings who are avatars of the
stones what becomes with the Watcher
what's the Watcher doing he's uh is
exclusive to the to the what if until
they announce their different timelines
Infinity watch could work uh I know
that's the storyline where each of the
stones has a has a human element they
did that like three years ago in the
comics I think the closest we'll get to
that is like kind of the representation
of Loki and maybe Scarlet Witch but I
don't know if they'll fully embody that
maybe for Kang Dynasty but I I doubt
they'll go that way but but they could
they
could hold on I could have just said it
now that you're done talking oh well
there you go all
right
oh Yara Yara just wanted to say love you
guys we love you too we love you too my
God hey Lorenzo Baxter good to see you
again it's been rough lately and your
stream is bright in my afternoon even
this one wow Coy any recommendations for
Marvel GL who knows nothing about comics
where to start thank you oh uh there's a
really good run of Captain Marvel if you
like uh the the character of Captain
Marvel Carol ders that is her origin
story that I just made a video about
like what to read from Miss Marvel for
Captain Marvel um check my Tik Tok it
say from a male perspective as a man
these are women's opinions is the uh but
no check out my Tik Tok I do uh like
lots of recommendations for individual
characters but uh I really a slept on
character that I think more people
should read is um the gwenpool character
who is fourth wall breaking in a really
unique way and that she is actually
aware of the Marvel Comics universe so
she knows everyone's secret identity so
she's really powerful because she like
just reads comics and I think that's a
really fun first comic for a new comic
reader so check out gwenpool yeah dude
Cy did look fresh in that reaction dude
was coming from charity yeah
this guy wanted to help feed people do
get more woke than that I mean the worst
I want to help
others so awake it's okay Chelsea
appreciate you being here right now
rickel hey which specific Heroes do you
guys want new Avengers team for Secret
Wars also I'm curious who would you say
is the best actor in the MCU in your
opinion I love you guys have a good day
all right okay okay honest answers right
now New Avengers team Secret Wars oh
dude it I want all the new people
who have not had a chance to cross over
yet shuni
shangi everyone is like just do what the
Avengers does do everything like
just get all the characters together
like it's not really a selective
processor just get everyone together
here yeah I think they're going to throw
a lot at the wall dude uh shangi
even shehulk that were in there and uh
everyone's got the Disney Plus shows
Echo Daredevil do it all I think that's
why I think that's why it's been so long
since we got an Avengers movie because
they're building it for just a massive
massive event I think people expect that
or nothing like it has to be they've
kind of programmed us for like few
movies Avengers few movies Avengers and
now it's been so long since we had a
crossover but I think they're building
up this thing because of the cataclysmic
kind of event we would have the it turns
the best after the MCU my God it's kind
of hard to narrow it down to one right
now Tom right now I just want to
celebrate Tom hon and Aman volani two
powerhouses like watching the evolution
of Tom hson has been phenomenal and
watching newcomer Aman volani who just
comes under the scene kill it
amazing man yeah yeah yeah I just really
want to celebrate them right now Changi
uh simu has to recovered from his
surgery I saw him at that charity event
that I was dressed so Spruce yet on
crutches you know rich people I'm saying
he's up and mobile and doing better he
was worried about true not racist it's
about me knowing people that's what it's
about Sean Peyton thank you Sean
hey Greg Coy I watched the Marvels last
night and it's a three star film I know
I might be in on liking it believe me
you're not but in my honest opinion ER
but the lack of clear story story was
something bringing it down I mean said
one or two really love the character of
Captain Marvel more now yeah know I
think it elevated her for me too I never
seen some people who really don't like
her still but I I liked her in this
movie quite a bit I I feel like it
really captured more for personality Coy
can you give two Young Avengers comic
recommendations uh check out Young
Avengers volume one by Chung the artist
uh C hu n is really good it has iron lad
stuff it deals with a lot of those those
Team Dynamics but then I'd also check
out Mark Wade's Champions I know it's
not a Young Avengers title but I think
they're going to draw the Young Avengers
from both of them so check out volume
one of each and see which one you like
more and then keep reading maybe maybe
I'd say uh read the first issue of Young
Avengers so that way you start just from
the very beginning proper original
context yeah go back to Avengers one
that's I always answer every one of my
questions that way it sounds like I know
what I'm talking let me just have a
foundation like which which blade comic
should read I think you should start
with the first one so you understand it
from the beginning tomb of Dracula go
back to tomb of Dracula where blade was
introduced it won't not make
sense Richie Brad I do standup but I
suck at it just like everyone seems to
think you guys suck at having opinions
wow was that part of your standup jokes
that really hurt what stream jeez I'd be
the guy in the crowd being like screw
you man man also like you said KO is a
little puppy all love oh my God you know
what I found myself looking at of course
we're going to do Echo reactions um who
was the guy who got cancelled from
Seinfeld Kramer guy yeah Richards yeah I
was like watching stuff with him and
funny uh no not I mean kind of it's just
funny how like Jerry Seinfeld
immediately came to his defense did he
yeah I missed that whole
Saga he did the stand up and then Jerry
Seinfeld immediately like you're going
on David Letter and you're going to
apologize and didn't seem to work I
don't know what he's doing I mean no
it's ruined his career forever it was a
terrible thing that I saw the video
again yeah I was like wow that really is
a bad
day yeah have you seen it no oh my god
do you know what he did no of why he was
cancelled I just know he got canceled oh
my God that is one of the like most
horrendous things I've ever seen at a
stand up like this is really awful
anyway look change the subject oh bullet
station's back Mobius for me is more is
hotter Anakin Shan
Peyton damn that's a racist 17y old it
is also I make more money on Tik Tok
than you probably make it a year Sean
Payton damn Coy there's no need to say
that I like punching down a 17-year-old
we been over this wait till I mean wait
till he's your age he can all most vote
he's never going to be my age unless I
die well no then I'm dead Greg how was
the aist horror movie my girlfriend are
going to see it for a birthday tomorrow
well it might not be as
exciting Ah lilan that's true I don't
think he deserves to be further dragged
down I mean I feel like he's really done
his best to make amends it just that
would seem like aggressively racist when
you watch it and I'm like hopefully he
has really learned you know hopefully
he's really
learned just think it was kind of crazy
to watch this random last night or
two nights
ago I don't want to regurgitate hatte
toward W him he really does seem super
depressed these
days I feel like really bad I feel bad D
brought history bad now aist anyway
shamp PNE Greg uh yeah I love the aist
tour I thought it was a beautiful
experience I've been listening to Taylor
stuff like every single day ever since I
even watched the uh Taylor Swift
documentary on Netflix uh Miss Americana
my God what the telling documentary I
think it brought me to tears on some
parts so yeah I mean it's more it's more
exciting the air store you got like a
crowd who really into it I don't know
how big it'll be now but hey man I mean
I just hope you have a fun time with
your girlfriend and hopefully uh you
know you guys do some fun stuff
afterwards you know what I mean sexual
things Trey Porter what are your top
five suits from the Matt MCU and the DCU
oh my God my top five suits from the MCU
well I will say I love Loki's new suit
oh my God recency bias that's for sure
love noi's new suit um I I actually
really like Iron Man suit and infinity
War a lot Captain America and winter
soldiering fine you know super fine um I
like Wanda's look and and Multiverse of
Madness quite a bit actually Doctor
Strange is pretty accurate a lot of the
suits look great to me goddamn
Chadwick and the Black Panther one oh my
God yeah uh I'm a big fan of let's see I
like Scarlet Witch's final suit uh like
I really think that's one of the things
I like about MTI vers of Madness I dig
Spider-Man's final suit I like where
things are about to go uh I really like
Iron Man's in two which is one of the
things I like about that movie uh what I
I like most of them I'm trying to think
of the more obscure ones um DCU I really
he can almost vote I love Wonder Woman I
love this dude I hope he's getting paid
to be here like we are because that is a
long time we're not getting paid to be
well it's it's we're I did this for a
year and a half without earning a dollar
well I know but now
people pay you it's not really a it's
kind of people don't understand all
right it's a different conversation the
DCU he's not getting paid for sure
though he needs a job what's the thing
this the thing in the DCU oh five suits
uh I really like Wonder Woman Men of
Steel
patley
Quin and
uh I don't know uh I didn't love
Superman's um I think really I loved it
oh like Ben Affleck a Batman suit I I
really dig um I
dig uh Harley Quinn suit in Birds of
Prey um I like we also to say positive
things is really Shazam
suit um and then the ones you said yeah
for sure man sorry I'm I'm brain dead I
can't even think of Suits dude Rick
all thanks Rick also for beyond the
spiderverse do you think we'll see the
original 616 Peter Parker from the
comics if so who should who do you think
should play him or should he speak
through speech I've been thinking of
that I'm wondering if Comics themselves
will be the next thing that blends into
the universe and that thing that'd be
really special especially if they had
Comics coming out simultaneously um I
don't think there should be a voice I
think it should be speech bubbles
because you can't hear when you're
reading comics and and if there's speech
then it's just another voiced character
so it' be unique if he had speech
bubbles I'd love that that's very true
that's very true it' be so dope to just
see dose thanks for the sicker will you
do Percy Jackson
reactions uh I'm I'm planning on
reacting to the movies with terara I
don't know about the show oh Dr Fate
suit top five for sure and then we got a
sticker here oh my God are we ending
like at 3:30 so Jolo Connell with a
sticker and I'll be back and then the
last thing here is this streamlabs this
one streamlab we must
honor just one yes okay all right so I
get the last one of the day uh I on yeah
but you hear different voices depending
on who you are so it wouldn't be one
voice Seth or we are going to spend 30
minutes on this yep hey guys I told this
koi on Twitter but Craig I appreciate
your reviews because you're actually in
CLE I will say my uh my my my My Talking
on the marbles was immediately not but I
feel like most of the time I do a really
I I give a effort even if I disagree
with you it makes me see things from a
different perspective I feel like I
become a better movie TV Watcher because
of your reviews that's true like most of
our reviews are done via like the
spoiler talks with the reactions and
stuff where we kind of talk for a long
time about it so I really appreciate
that Seth that's very kind very kind to
you and and like most people a lot of
people listen cos not variety hour a
high top um and you know even like
Double Toasted Jeremy John's I listen to
all these people you know uh Dan Merl
haroff I disagree with them so much of
the time initially but I always love
hearing other people red letter media I
always love hearing other people's
perspectives if it doesn't just seem
like they are doing something to plate
to Their audience and they expect like
you know there are certain channels
where it's like you know what they're
going to say because you just know what
they tend to but there's other channels
where like the guys that just listen to
you that I'm always curious even if I'm
going to disagree I love to hear it out
and I never I never fume no matter how
much in disagreeance I am sometimes
they're just sometimes they'll be really
funny to me even if I disagree I'll
still find them like hilarious yeah you
know so yeah man uh I really appreciate
it very much thank you man appreciate
that uh thank you guys so much for being
here do got to end this stream oh my god
let's not too bad 3:30 thank you guys so
much really loved being here this was a
really fun time yeah they're going to
film it later off today later on today
for Madagascar 2 for everyone who's been
here since the beginning um incred thank
you Koy obligatory Flex time obligatory
Flex We Flex the end of crazy you're
getting stations between your elbow like
this little area is so hard to get that
cut I don't know I I mean it's the
punches man I've been doing a
lot of forearm man a lot of for
once I realized my forearms were
small you were like no not in this house
yeah but but you got that natural bulk
again it's not natural I mean you got
that bulk you got the bulk I look like
I'm skinny until I Flex sure
you're like what up deal with it it's
not just
bones but thank you guys again um
seriously and for everyone who's been
really kind and been able to have
respectful disagreements about things
app really been appreciative and overall
this is one we are never going to forget
that's for sure thank you very much much
love to everyone